and Frank before you go
once the crew lock is at approximately
DP DT zero you are going to close the
Emer hatch mpev the Emer empev
and koichi will be closing the EV hatch
mpev
packaging um appreciate it we're not
going anywhere we're going to watch
these guys uh exit off that hatch
oh my goodness
all right to close the EV intent
thank you
okay so uh after hats open uh
I closed the evm now correct
that is correct Gucci
okay okay
right now inside the crew log the two
space walking astronauts uh are on the
other side of that hatch that's the crew
lock they're facing opposite directions
so
um it's actually koichiwakata the ev1
position with the red stripes when the
crew lock dpdt is approximately 0 you
can expect an alert tone
maybe two copies
okay crew we show you less than 0.5 PSI
you are go to open and Stow the EV hatch
koichi you'll then close the Eevee hatch
empez and Frank you'll close the
emergency Empire
right down a little bit okay
foreign
you're getting a look at the outside of
the International Space Station now the
International Space Station in orbital
night time so it's being illuminated by
the lights outside right now we're
zoomed in on the hatch
um
the thermal cover is still covering the
hatch but we did get confirmation the
hatch itself is open
again the official start time of the
spacewalk does not occur until the
astronauts switch to battery power
Ed
in the process of fully opening
I opened the uh EV
[Applause]
hatch empath
excuse me yeah I misspoke it was
UHF is closed
okay copy Evie hatch is open and stowed
and the EV hatch mpev is closed
because the emergency room is also
closed
okay copy emergency hatch empath is
closed all right with that ev1 and ev2
on your DCM switch power to bat stagger
your switch throws and extract the
warning tone
you have a battery
copy ev1 and 2 are in battery switch
your display to Pro to verify a
functional display
all right I'm still displayed APK
functional display
copy on the UIA switch power for ev1 and
2 off and check that the LEDs for ev1
and 2 that's four LEDs total are off
foreign
from your DCM and install the DCM in its
cover
Ed copies didn't work
foreign
with that the uh
two space walkers have switched their uh
spacesuit powers to battery that marks
the official start for today's space
walk we got a clock up on the board uh
and so we're looking at 7 14 a.m central
time for the official start of today's
spacewalk
foreign
TV series connected and so
okay copy your su's are disconnected and
stowed and make sure you have your DCM
cover installed
security
check depressed pump man ISO valve
closed
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
switch water on
everyone
waters on
check DCM blank and bite is off
set your temperature control valve as
desired report to MCC and reminder to
report all subsequent tcv changes
[Music]
52 GCV 4.
okay copy five and four report your suit
P gauge to MCC
age 4.3
copy 4.3 for both of you
set your visors as required you'll be
coming out into a night pass
thank you
okay crew with that you are ready to
open the hatch thermal cover
you'll release the hook from the
magnetic plate d-ring attach the hook to
the stowage tether point and cinch the
strap until it's snug with six lines
visible
now pushing the uh fabric thermal cover
that's on the outside of the cool locks
hatch
see him pushing that sort of out of the
way the hatch is open all the steps that
they've been doing up to this point is
really the closeout procedures for
everything they've been working on for
the depressurization getting their suits
ready they've already checked their
tethers
um right now uh they'll push open the
thermal hatch and they'll exit one at a
time we'll caught it first since he's
the one the uh
device visible
copy koichi
or go to egress the airlock once you've
egressed turn on your hakka Duke for you
you'll be retrieving the cable bag and
prepping it to pass the cuichi once he's
out
thermal copper is open wakada now
exiting the hatch
the hecka that was mentioned is the high
definition camera that's mounted on the
spacesuits helmet
foreign
following along throughout the spacewalk
you'll be able to notice him by the suit
with the red stripes
Nicole Mann uh call sign Duke she'll be
coming out afterwards both of them will
do a tether configuration check once
again they already did one inside the
house they'll do it again outside
configure their suits and make sure they
have all the materials needed before
they translate out
foreign
okay
and uh you can give me the
people there
okay I see that
come on
these silver reels you see floating in
front of ev1 koichiwakata with the red
stripes those are the tethers that I
mentioned they'll be doing a tether
check once both of them are outside the
hatch and you can sort of see Duke ev2
Nicole Mann
um exiting the hatch after wakata they
are in a night pass right now although
very soon they'll be uh seeing an
orbital Sunrise
okay okay here we go
okay you got it
[Applause]
Duke you'll Stow that ret on the airlock
d-ring extender and when you're ready
you can transfer the strut bag out to
ev1
[Music]
[Applause]
okay you got ready to receive it
okay I'm not physically
okay so I'm gonna
go thank you
[Applause]
in the corner
and I'm trying to get the bottom end for
two
let me come in a little bit to grab it
okay
still
can you fix it down towards the yeah
let's see
you need to go a little bit of the
fabric side effects
[ __ ]
ing
okay that's now cleared
[Applause]
that's a good direction orientation okay
stand by there's a little tangle here
okay
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
check that
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
so you see the rat from the cable bag
it's from the neighboring extender up to
the top of the earth
it is uh
okay so let me kind of
yeah about this
that because it's uh it's going through
your
giving extender let me could you come
down a little bit
closer
yeah
good direction and then
um
okay
okay
now I think it's uh
[Music]
oh yeah
it's going through
um
right
I didn't
okay all right I have all the way
towards the hatch here okay
grab it
and that's right
coming down
yeah
and then
okay yeah it's coming nicely
[Applause]
it's looking good okay looking good
[Applause]
okay I continued to pull it out
foreign
[Applause]
with all of the pieces necessary for
them to construct it right now this is a
picture from a previous strut with an
open bag you can see all of the
different components today we'll be
working on taking this and turning it
into the fully constructed modification
kit the 1A Channel this is a very
important piece of equipment that's
going to be making its way with the
astronauts they're gonna attach it to
themselves as they move out to the work
site today
top hand rail of the crew look that
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
all right and it's clear you can come
out okay
Houston's following along and we like
the plan for that rent as well you can
leave it where it is
okay
looking good
welcome
okay YouTube's coming out okay and the
strut bag is to your left
and you can just come down straight down
okay I'm gonna go extension aft okay
copy that I'll move the chat back a
little bit more to the port side
should be clean now
okay I've got a local film okay looks
good
okay I'm gonna get out um
[Applause]
today I see it on okay
I'm gonna work on my brt puppy PRT is
the body restraint tether for uh Duke
with uh no Stripes she'll be attaching
that strut bag to her body restraint
Heather attached to uh koichi is a bag
full of cables on his way over to the 1B
work site he's gonna stop along the way
and temporarily Stow that bag full of
cables for the work later on uh while uh
man or Duke has the
um uh job of taking that strut bag over
to the 1A Channel
foreign
when they talk to each other they'll be
doing buddy checks and
um seeing how each other's spacing looks
and reporting that to each other uh they
do have some procedures to make sure all
of their suit components are in a good
spot before they actually translate or
move over
but these uh procedures are all about
communication Houston copies and once
you've got your International Space
Station number is over the South Pacific
Ocean right now we're entering into an
orbital daytime so you're seeing the sun
rise over the horizon of the Earth right
now
[Applause]
yourself
okay so your umbilical is set
yeah yeah
okay
yeah that should be clear let me get it
back in the couch though
I'll look at it and why don't you do the
uh
yeah
yeah
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
and thank you crew we appreciate you
taking care of the seu it doesn't need
to go back in its pouch we appreciate it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I got the other adjustable on me so I'm
gonna put it in the jars now that's it
and hold it here
towards your head
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
okay
and then uh
give me the body check after that
Houston copies on you guys are looking
great
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and
[Applause]
both later handles let me check the
website is done
tether is good
okay
okay I think your screen has that your
green wzs your lights are on that was
good I've got one two three tabs up
under many workstation
um look at your handles okay okay you
got one
and two safer handles are down okay I
see your feet together looks like
there's a good conservative
[Applause]
okay crew we'll take a baseline hap from
both of you
um
to
okay copy good Baseline hat for both of
you you can take a couple minutes here
to do some translation adaptation so
play around with your body rotation
pitch yaw roll various hand grips
translation without rotation and try
attaching a local tether and releasing
both hands just a reminder this first
hour will set your medox or the rest of
the Eva so just take it nice and
deliberate take it easy
getting some
wonderful views from the outside of the
International Space Station right now
the duo are just at the beginning of
their planned six and a half hour
spacewalk they're getting a sunrise over
the South Pacific Ocean
and we're getting a great high
definition views from their helmet
cameras right now they just finished
performing buddy checks and you heard
the ground division of Cartman uh
telling them to take their time of
course they have done plenty of
spacewalk training including here on the
ground at the Johnson Space Center here
in Houston is a laboratory called the
neutral buoyancy laboratory where they
practice these things underwater it is a
very good analog for understanding what
it's like in the microgravity
environment but the two of them now are
first-time space Walkers so they're
going to take some time on the outside
of the hatch to just get used to
understanding the differences between uh
performing the spacewalk in a pool with
the resistance of water and having no
resistance in the vacuum of space
their translation path or their movement
out to the work site is is all the way
out on the wings of the International
Space Station on the solar arrays so
they do have a quite a bit of of
translation to go to so they're just
sort of getting their bearings making
sure they understand their movements
before they make that Journey
and once again we have another increment
Gap in communication from the
International Space Station we mentioned
being over the South Pacific Ocean at
this time throughout today's spacewalk
we'll see gaps like these the space
station communicates by way of
geosynchronous satellites called the
tdrs network tracking and data relay
satellites will get intermittent gaps of
audio and video sometimes we regain the
audio a little bit earlier
because now you're hearing the audio
come from the International Space
Station so we'll be regaining that
shortly teams here in Mission Control
Houston are monitoring today's space
walk as well as the International Space
Station and the crew inside uh it'll be
the teams here that are walking our
astronauts through today's procedures
Xena Cartman you see in the middle there
uh with the black blazer and the white
shirt uh that is uh NASA astronaut Xena
Cartman ground IV it's her voice uh
that's being communicated uh from all
the work that the teams are doing here
in Mission Control Houston she's
Translating that up to the crew
it's an awesome view here
and standby one koichi we're actually
checking on the seus in the airlock
great
we're having the IV crew check on that
through the hatch window
s for your awareness on your left side
your feathers are over the top of the
BLT
it's gonna be a problem just when you
are after you get that bag off you're
gonna
I understand that yeah thanks
[Applause]
thanks
foreign
big big
okay crew we're back with you we did see
one of the su's came out of its pouch
but we are actually good with that as
long as the thermal cover is tended
closed and so with that you can go ahead
and start translating ev1 you'll be
translating out to the Anchor hooks that
are Nader of the starboard seating
Duke if you contend the hatch thermal
cover closed that's very helpful
continue your translation adaptations
foreign
and the Journey Begins now that uh
they've done all that they can on the
outside of the airlocks hatch
um getting all of their tools attaching
it to their body their strength tether
making sure their tethers are in a good
configuration sort of doing an
adaptation uh now we're following Luigi
wakana with the high definition camera
and he's translating or moving out to
the work site so he's going to begin his
journey
foreign
foreign
foreign
just a reminder as you translate to also
keep your cable bags and strut bags in
your skin so that they don't hit
anything either
you have copies
for those just tuning in uh we're
following along uh by way of the helmet
camera of kawichiwakata
they've exited the hatch and started
their spacewalk officially at 7 14 a.m
central time uh did some buddy checks
and made sure they had all their tools
attached to them you can see they are
attached to his body restraint to other
uh koichiwakata has a cable bag in tow
right now he's heading over to the S4
truss section of the truss he's going to
leave that cable back there and then go
to the 1B work site they're splitting up
to begin with uh is going to drop off
that bag and then finish up tightening
constructed um
mounting platform that's on the 1B truss
he's just got to use that pistol grip
tool or basically a cordless drill to
tighten some bolts not much work there
it's really just going to take the first
hour uh of his uh of his task while
Nicole Man by call sign Duke will be
hearing that over space to ground today
she's going to go over to the directly
to the 1A work site with the strut bag
in tow that strut bag has the mounting
platform itself in it so she'll begin
the construction there while
uh koichi wakata finishes up the
construction on the 1B site and then for
the remainder of today's space walk the
two will focus on working together to
construct that mounting platform on the
1A Channel
foreign
puppy that I see that chair
[Applause]
in the middle of the frame there it uh
you you can see a
digital camera the lens is the thing
that makes it the most apparent but it's
covered with insulation to protect it
uh from the thermal environment outside
the International Space Station so uh
kuichiwakata will be able to take some
photos both for engineering purposes to
show the work that they're doing as well
as take some beautiful photos of Earth
and of the work outside
at the hook
that'd be Gucci and that's one handrail
three two one seven
foreign
ER
that's the example
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
that's too uh
from three two one seven eight close the
clock and if we have a go to release
your race cutter from the Air Max
Houston copy is looking good
foreign
[Music]
extender and thermal cover closed
with that you can start translating Duke
after the one alpha work site and just
take it slow and easy and before you
cross the Stars check that your
gauntlets aren't
come on
[Applause]
make sure that your gauntlets are in
place before you cross the Sarge
in place I'm gonna go to the website
perfect
from phase one you'll be trending Zenith
to the non-radiator edge looking for S4
handrail 2219 when you get out there
[ __ ] is that 22-19
foreign
trending average for the rest of the Eva
copy Duke
foreign
for those following along you're seeing
a split screen here from the high
definition helmet cameras on both of our
space Walkers today
koichiwakata making his way out to the
1B Channel he's going to stop along the
way and he's got a a bag a cable bag in
tow on his body restraint tether and has
some of the cables for some of the
secondary work as well as well as GoPros
some of the other tools and materials
that they need for the non-primary
work that they're doing while Nicole
Mann or call sign Duke has the strut bag
that's the primary thing that they're
doing Nicole man just finished up her
work that she had to make sure the
thermal cover on the Eva hatch was
closed and make sure there's no thermal
fluctuation inside of the crew lock
where they just exited to begin today's
space walk both of them now translating
or moving out to their respective work
sites
typically targeting high definition
views this is Nicole man call sign Duke
she's wearing the suit with no stripes
and she's got that giant bag with her
that's the strut bag that has the
mounting platform uh that they're going
to be installing today both of them will
be uh working on the 1A channel
koichiwakata has got to make a stop
first to work on the 1B
um but Nicole man's gonna get uh get
started right away so she's got that bag
in tow she'll be able to unbuckle uh
some of the straps that are holding
those components in place uh retrieve
some of the materials and it is a
they'll be installing it one at a time
the ground teams have plenty of
experience with this type of work this
is this will be the sixth modification
kit this is these struts to attach to a
mass canister so they're prepared for uh
any of uh issues or troubleshooting they
need to do along the way
or the movement
stand by Gucci you'll need to actually
backtrack just a little bit let me give
you a good handrail pass
okay
okay so uh
come down a little bit and then uh
foreign
you're doing a good thing you can head
outboard from there that was a good move
going towards your feet
okay two two one nine is what I have so
I keep going
that's perfect you'll be pausing here to
Stow the cable bag so this is the
inboard non-radiator corner
so that will be on hand Nails 2219 and
2215 using integral tethers with the
hands okay
okay copy that I see them
because I was really close
actually I'm coming underneath the empty
okay copy that
part about the sensor location of the
cable deck
the Venus that's so uh
orientation is the handrail away from
the uh
of course the radiator side is that
right that's correct the handrail
towards the radiator and koichi will
actually have you hang out there for
just a second as we know every medox
canister is a different character uh
yours is trending a little bit high
right now pause and make sure that we
can maintain that good medox canister
for the rest of the Eva
okay copy that
okay so I'm passing our uh okay
thanks
okay koichi thanks for hanging for a sec
we'll have you Stow that cable bag again
with the handrail toward the radiator
2219 and 2215.
foreign
foreign
we see you both looks like you've got
good eyes on for decomplexion
again
copy gauntlets down Duke
foreign
[Music]
that perfect good config
with that you can fair lead on annual
two two one nine
and we'll have to translate out to your
green hook location
interface and then over the apron with
the Venus non-radiator side and just a
reminder to take it really nice and slow
and easy we've got that trending High
Maddox canister so just take your time
thank you
foreign
okay
okay
[Music]
okay Tina I'm going to continue upwards
copy Duke you'll be following the
keelside non-radiator edge
following handrail 2219 and continuing
outboard to 2231
foreign
for those following along we're getting
high definition fuse from the outside of
the International Space Station the two
space Walkers are going to be splitting
up for the first of their tasks
koichiwakata translating over to the 1B
work site he had a cable bag in tow
along the way and stored it in a
location so they can easily access it
later there's some materials in there
they need for some future work that's
later in the timeline for now though
koichiwakana really only needs his
pistol grip tool the mounting platform
on the 1B channel was constructed on a
previous Eva and really just needs a
little bit of tightening and some last
minute work to finish it up so he can do
that by himself he's just going to use
that do that for about the first hour of
the spacewalk once he gets there that'll
really start the clock for him to
perform some of that work in the
meantime you're watching ev2 Nicole Mann
call sign Duke translating or moving out
to The One a channel in tow she's got a
strut bag that's the strut are going to
actually be building together wakata
will join man later in today's spacewalk
she'll just get a head start and start
some of that work here soon
okay
okay copy that Duke and a reminder for
koichi just a quick caution to minimize
loads into the wire ties that are on
that mli there uh should be right nearby
handrail 2008.
okay I see that thank you
foreign
that strut bag as you know I'm sure on
the outboard non-radiator corner of the
iea looking for handrails two two two
two two two two three
and two two five one but that's also up
here we're not gonna
go towards the mass canister or the
radiator
awesome
okay Green Hope is attached to handrail
207-2007
coffee green Hook is down with that you
can translate out toward the one Bravo
mask canister
and reminder that at the one broker iea
you'll be Crossing to the radiator side
so follow S6 handrail 2032
32
copy that Duke
foreign
and I can't wait to the uh outboard to
go to the
left side of the uh
[Applause]
yeah you'll be Crossing to the radiator
side and on the radiator side heading
outboard to the mass canister
oh
and yes you will be going to the left
side of the mod kit with that we'll take
a glove hap and Gauntlet check
okay after I get there let's do it we'll
be to do it now
clubs are good happy strike
copy good gloves and hap
and we also see that you're going
through it yes you can
great copy that
I got uh
and I'm gonna get one more
copy Duke
and a big picture update for both of you
you're pretty much right on the timeline
and are limiting consumable right now is
medox with a 630 pet
puppy
this has a good report from the ground
IV uh xenocardmen along the way the
teams continue to monitor the progress
through the procedures as well as
something called limiting consumables uh
the spacesuits that they're wearing and
has everything they need in terms of
life support it has it provides the
pressure the air provides water it also
provides battery power everything is
portable as they do this work outside of
the International Space Station now an
hour into today's space walk we plan for
six and a half hours uh everything seems
to be on track in terms of the timeline
and the limiting consumables they'll
continue to monitor this throughout as
it could fluctuate but right now we're
looking good until it's fully installed
Friday
that's perfect
all right copy Duke with that you can
translate inboard to the starboard Ceta
with one and grab that apfr
foreign
for you once you're at the left collar
bolts
you'll be going outboard under the VGA
platform on the Broom okay you're there
you'll be opening the mli around the
middle to access the collar bolts
okay
okay I see that I opened MMI I can
access to those like Hollow bolts
that's perfect I've got a great view in
your hecka now okay I have PGT settings
for you when you're ready
on the
Best Shot
and I'm ready for a PGT settings
okay great and just a quick reminder
here while you're brt to that midstreet
handrail minimize normal intortional
loads into the midstret your PGT
settings will be Bravo 7 clockwise too
level seven clockwise too
so right now koichiwakata is at the work
site of the 1B Channel you can sort of
see the these struts on the right side
of the mass canister that's taking on
most of the center of the flame there
um the mounting platform on the 1B
channel is constructed he's got the
pistol grip Tool uh basically a cordless
power drill they have cordless they have
uh the torque settings uh programs into
the tools so they know exactly how much
torque uh to to work on to the various
parts of the struts so he's on the left
side right now he opened the multi-layer
insulation the white fabric to access
the bolt on the left side so he'll be
the the first part of his task is to
work on some of the bolts there
foreign
driving m29 and m30 to torque we're
expecting about four to six turns
looking for turn count torque and green
light
I'll be there total fixtures expected
[Music]
I'm going to uh
if it's took off on Olympics
I don't know
[Applause]
okay then I got a green light and I
talked about when I see uh
Focus 25.5
.8 and the revolution is uh
I counted the three and a half and a
half visually but it says
Evolution who said zero two nine on the
BGG
y hey copy 25.8 on the torque and three
and a half turns counted visually
looking for a green light as well and to
confirm that was m29
I don't see a label here
all right koichi we're going to talk
about the turn count on that one but
while we're doing that you can go to the
other bolts and same number okay turns
expected about four to six looking for a
torque and green light as well
great copy
so again the pistol grip tool that
cordless power drill that kuichiwakata
is holding now
um has the turn count and the torque
settings he's tightening with a
clockwise rotation the different color
bolts on the left part of the mounting
platforms strut
he tightened one and as the ground teams
assessed that color bolt settings he'll
be working on the next
popped out
you can retrieve the workout and apfr
and stow it on your brt when you're
ready and translate out to S4
15
[Music]
just came up and I see uh
and uh
which you're coming in a little broken
there could you repeat your last I heard
two turns and did not copy the rest
okay uh I visually confirmed the two
terms on the upper bolt and I got the
two uh lights the low torque and uh talk
about yourself 20.2 and I don't see any
turn counts on the PGT
foreign
we'll have you try that bolt again just
make sure you're in a good body position
for uh leverage on that PGT and we'll
have you hit the upper bolts one more
time
okay
[Music]
thank you
okay yeah yeah
completely another a little over one
third I got a green light in front down
in the
talk about you 25.5 in the
is 1.42
okay copy one additional turn green
five decimal decimal five on the torque
we'll we'll talk about those numbers for
just a moment here
okay
foreign
we'll have you move on here we're going
to set the PGT to manual ratchet
clockwise and then you'll be driving m29
and 30. until you get two MTL pops so
we'll expect several extra turns here
just keep an eye out and give us a turn
count visually
copy that
is
do the manual on the game lower Cycles
copy starting with the lower Bolt
s
good news you can translate
okay yeah on the lower balls that
two tops and the whole turn is
approximately 90 degrees
a quarter of a turn Okay copy one
quarter additional turn and two pops on
the MTL
ers
but meanwhile you can go to the upper
bolts and do the same thing in manual
ratchet
copy that
let's do a quick recap there are two
bolts on this left strut that
koichiwakata is working at we're looking
at him his helmet camera view and using
the pistol grip tool to hand tighten
each of the bolts now that he's done a
rotation just hand tightening the
Adaptive torque in the meantime Nicole
Mann is on the other work side she's
preparing and grabbing the materials she
needs including a workout strain to
start constructing uh the mounting
platform
um from from koichi wakado's view you
can see sort of the final product of
that mounting platform on the 1B Channel
that's what they'll be building on 1A
instead of using the manual reset it
rotated about the capital and still does
not pop
py has a turn you can keep going if
you're able we want to get two MTL pops
to go to continue we'll look for two
empty cups on the other one
okay
completely
okay copy two pops complete on the upper
bolts were there any additional turns
after that happened
uh another uh
another quarter turn and two pops on the
upper okay give us just a second to talk
about that bolt okay
all right
and what we give the myrrh and Eva a
moment to talk about that you can just
put some photos for your awareness your
net rate is looking really good right
now it's looking a lot better
yeah definitely trending better from
before
foreign
as a reminder for you before you cross
the sarge check that your gauntlets are
in place
already in place thank you
foreign
intermittent Gap in Communications from
the International Space Station
the teams here in Houston's Mission
Control are overseeing the spacewalk for
today
two space walking astronauts
kawichiwakada and Nicole Mann working on
upgrades to the power Channel and some
of the prep work needed for the arrival
of irosas or International Space Station
roll out solar arrays later this summer
they'll be working on two mounting
platforms one on the 1B Channel and
another on the 1A
koichiwakata is already at the 1B
Channel tightening some bolts as part of
the final steps to make sure that
mounting platform is secure it's
expected that that's going to take just
the first hour or so of the spacewalk
and he's already getting on a great
timeline for getting that work done
which is great news so if you haven't
already you can set your PGT back to
motor and stow it
then close the mli to cover the
particles
and that note from Xena Cardman here in
Mission Control saying that the two
bolts on the left collar are complete so
he's going to close up the multi-layer
insulation sort of the white fabric that
protects it thermally from the vacuum
space and the harshness of the Sun and
he'll work on some of the next struts
the next one should be the mid strut
that I'll be working on in the meantime
Nicole Mann is prepping her work site
which is the 1A Channel she's getting
some materials she needs she's got uh
she already stowed the bag that has the
um the struts inside and those struts
will be what will be used to actually
construct the mounting platform on the
Mast canister of the 1A Channel she got
the foot restraint
retrieved it from one of the work sites
and you can sort of see it attached to
her right now from this view on the
outside of the space station that foot
restraint is going to help to access
some of the areas that are needed for
actually constructing that mounting
platform she'll be able to Ingress or or
enter that that foot restraint and give
her leverage that she needs to actually
drive some of the bolts and actually
construct the mounting platform so she's
got that in tow and she's going to be
going over to the 1A work site very soon
to get it ready uh wakuichi wakada
continues to finish up the work on the
1B side
foreign
uh
okay copy that koichi we don't have your
hecka right now
with that and translate to the right
side
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
golfers already and let me know when
you're ready for the extension
foreign
and of course we'll be looking for black
on black with a good pull test as well
you're looking at the helmet camera of
Duke uh NASA astronaut Nicole Mann she's
at the 1A work site right now and you
see her installing the uh articulating
portable foot restraint this foot
restraint has the ability to have some
settings to angle the foot restraints so
that it can reach predetermined marks
that are needed for the upcoming work to
actually install some of the struts so
she's uh installing that right now she's
going to check the the settings on the
articulating portable photo stream make
sure it's really at the right angle so
that she can access some of the first
bolts and areas that she needs to access
for some of the upcoming work
foreign
guys will be flying over Japan in a
couple minutes wave hello for us
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
pull twist test and a clocking of six uh
we'll also take a black on black check
for that in color
I guess black on black
foreign
copy and the extension there will be
five for the with x
you got one side thank you already
headed over the other side
uh yeah I know the uh left uh right side
now
yeah how's it going with you hey I got
the uh
on the triangle right
to uh the two first-time space Walkers
sharing their progress for today
right side I'm hoping opening
uh
you take a hecka cycle from both of you
just one button push on your hekka
and correction just koichi
[ __ ]
okay
okay it has to be on now
do you see that we copied That Gucci
it'll probably take us about a minute
before we see any change here
but for now uh we hear that you are in
place you can open the mli around the
mid-struct collar to access those bolts
M25 and M26 okay and I'll have bgt
settings when you're ready
okay is that right
foreign
[Applause]
sticks
kuichi for you PGT settings will be
Bravo 7 clockwise too
okay
the Breville seven uh clockwise two is
that correct hey from Bravo 7 clockwise
two
foreign
pointed towards unlocked papa papa
now we have both helmet camera views
from koiji wakata and the Coleman
they're pushing up on it
I don't know if you have any ideas
copy Duke that sounds like a good plan
I got a lower about the green lights
25.4 foot pounds four points one four
turns
question
4.179 turns
the green light
25.4 on the torque and four turns
visually
and the visitation is 4.79 turns
speak Ouija
you can go to M26 now this is the other
Bolt
same deal we're expecting about four or
six turns copy that
'll be work
please uh you know as we talked about
I'm going to move on to the triangle
until community so we can work together
on that pitch
okay copy that Duke
so if you want to one other thing you
can try is using the boot plate for some
extra Leverage
but again we'll take your expertise here
I'm happy to wait until koichi gets
there you can also do the rest of the
apfr settings if you'd like
so a quick recap of where we are we're
seeing both the helmet cameras of koichi
bukata and Duke uh on the left
working on the mid strut there's the
various components of the mounting
platform he's asking for the settings
that are needed on his screen or this
power drill to drive some of her bolts
and on the right side Duke is preparing
the work site for installing a mounting
platform on the one age handle and she's
working on portable foot restraint you
can see sort of the area where her feet
will soon go later in the timeline
making sure that that's in a good
configuration so they're both at two
different work sites right now
visually instead more than four
okay copy that's perfect about five
turns with that you can set your PGT to
manual ratchet clockwise and you'll be
torquing both of those bolts looking for
any additional turns report those to us
and two MTL pops on each
do that
and
copy Duke great work
so same as he did with the left strut on
the Min strut koiji wakata is uh first
using the pistol grip tool to uh Drive
uh with the tool itself followed by some
manual ratcheting to finalize the torque
on each of the bolts
so right now he's working on that
mid-stride and then once again we're um
in a Handover period so we're going to
temporarily lose some of the video and
audio from the space station beginning
audio first it seems like we're getting
some sounds from the space station back
with you guys after a quick Handover
koichi we were tracking you were in
manual projects but have not heard the
report yet and Duke were tracking you're
working on the API
another
[Applause]
copy two pots additional quarter turn on
the lower bolts
is to say my two pumps they got getting
the additional quarter turns
okay copy two pops an additional quarter
turn that's a good bolt on both of those
so with that you can set your PGT back
to motor and sell it you can also now
translate on the one Brava mod kit
[Applause]
thing I can translate to uh one half
about the game right
yeah after this you'll be uh closing the
mli on the collarbolts and yes you can
translate on the OnePlus project
okay I understand copy that
Duke if you feel like that apfr is
behaving you can feel free to continue
work on it but we can also have you
pause and head to the upper triangle and
wait for koichi to get over there
it's about halfway there
so as we regain video back from the
International Space Station
hey firm we've got a heck of you and
copy the mli
okay
the max is the heck again from the uh on
the bracket
copy the mli over the collar bolts is
just out of our view in your heka right
now so if you can reposition just a
smidge we'll take a look but we'll also
just trust your eyes on whether that's
covering the collar bolts
have you let me know which direction I
need to move
yeah you look great there koichi
we can have you head to the mounting
bracket
check that it's clear of mli
and you'll probably have an even better
view from over there
that's not about halfway there and it's
um
talk so when I get to uh
tool I'll use the tool but I'm still
working on the show and go right now
copy that plan Duke we like it so we've
got tango tango Fox 12 those are good
settings but the pitch knob is still uh
not back out
um and I like the plan to start working
on the triangle we'll come back with the
tool
foreign
[Music]
we're taking a look there it's a little
bit dark in your camera view
we'll trust your uh visual report as
well
okay so uh
[Music]
Friday
is spread out pretty well in the right
side I can still a little bit before
area
and uh there's still
um
and I can sit you down a little
firmly down
okay koichi we copy all um you're ahead
of the timeline right now so we'll use
this time to have you go over and adjust
that mli just take care of whatever Gap
you see
okay copy that
and koichiwakan is still working on the
1B site he's uh gonna take some time
that white fabric that's on the outside
of these struts just make sure that's
nice and tight
um
Duke Nicole man on the 1A site uh
working on the portable foot restraint
uh she's also going to start building
the different components of the mounting
platform starting with the upper
triangle the the top most part of the
mounting bracket you want me to do
another HEPA scan
copy glitchy checking
okay I'm already there and uh often
brackets and I don't know if you can see
the heck of you but uh yeah the analy is
covering
[Applause]
copy Gucci that's a good view we're
taking a look
okay koichi we're taking a look and we
see a flap of mli open on the
telescoping end
of the strut if you see that as well
we'll have you go over and see if you
can get that to close with the velcro
[Applause]
right
hey from Gucci
copy that it works
Engineers on the ground assessing the
configuration of the mounting platform
where koichiwakata is currently working
we're getting a view from his home the
camera there looking at the multi-layer
insulation that white fabric they just
really want to make sure it's covered
very nicely and once it's in a good
Refrigeration you get confirmation from
the ground teams that they're happy with
it and koichi makata will be able to
move on to the next task
but
we use this integrated wire tie to
secure this uh
uh a little bit open an eye does it look
good to you that looks beautiful we
really like that
with that we can have you depart this
worksite and you'll be translating over
to one alpha
copy that translating
that's perfect you'll head to the iea
Via that right lower strut
minimize translation on the midstret if
you can and then you'll be going inward
on the S6 iea
at the inboard Edge across to the
non-radiator side
for collegi wakato there are three main
tasks that he needs to accomplish over
at the mounting platform uh he was
working his way basically clockwise
around the mounting platform he started
on the left side to work on two bolts
then completed the the mid-strut bolts
now he's going to complete his work by
tightening the two bolts that are on the
right side of course checking that
multi-layer insulation that white fabric
along the way making sure that looks
good but once he's done he'll really uh
proceed into some cleanup steps and then
go over to translate to the 1A worksite
where Nicole Mann is currently starting
to construct some of the components of
the of the mounting bracket over there
and then they'll work on that side
together
okay copy that Duke you can keep that
Tethered to the bag lock out the threat
if you need to you'll be aligning the
right upper strut L7 to the mounting
bracket right side
check that the alignment tab is in the
groove and the black lines are aligned
on the end of the mounting bracket I'll
have PGT settings when you're ready
foreign
Duke is building the mounting bracket
you can see from this graphic right here
what that's going to look like so that
upper part with the sort of pinkish
purple part is the upper triangle she's
right now building that first so she's
getting a head start on there and it's
going to attach to what's called The
Mask canister that's that greenish
bluish soda can looking structure that's
where the Legacy solar arrays were
originally deployed from and this is
really a sort of an adapter to allow the
irosa solar arrays to attach to the
mounting bracket that's that sort of
bluish Indigo Parts labeled there on the
left I throw some mounting bracket so
she's just right now building that that
upper structure
foreign
hey koichi if you can pause right there
you'll be following yourself each other
back in board to the one alpha work site
we see you not quite translating in the
right path
it looks like it's a
if I'm tired
to my left that's what I was following
that
yeah I do see that so on the
inboard edge of the iea we would have
you cross back over to the non-radiator
side you can also follow the handrails
that are in front of you to the other
side of the iea
copy that
at the end of the iea city on radiator
sides
that's perfect koichi
once you're on the non-radiator side you
can head inboard along the Zenith Edge
you'll follow S6 handrail 2008
and you'll be picking up your green Hook
from S6 handrail 2007.
copy that pick up green hooker
foreign
I didn't hear the PGT settings
clockwise II and uh just working on M14
here perfect okay we're expecting
approximately four turns on M13 and M14
this is not to torque yet
that's perfect
I think now I see you
okay
all right
[Applause]
because you and I got uh one Lantern on
13 and 14. moving on to the PGT for
three more
okay copy one hand turn on M13 and M14
.
three more turns on M14
copy three additional turns on M14
that's four total
except the green hook and I'm
translating
copy quiche you'll be at the S5 S6
interface following the A-frame Nader
follow handrail 2144
and then on the Nader forward Edge
translate to the inboard edge of the one
alpha iea
because you're not moving on to uh
probably Duke
and Duke those are straps one and two
for the left upper and I'll have PGT
settings new settings
foreign
[Applause]
hello Duke hey creepy
I've got upper right on the center
triangle I'm going to work on that
Center pad now okay copy um
it's giving me a hard time good job okay
you want to give it a try or uh try the
tool all the settings okay I'll try that
thank you
it just needs to be lost they're locked
okay copy
yeah good coordination for both of you
koichi if you do want to grab the
Crowfoot tool that's Deering hotel in
the strut bag you'll need the ratchet
wrench as well
um also Duke if it would help you to
have an extra pair of hands you can work
together on the upper triangle and then
we'll go back to the apfr
I recommend Collective
right there
copy that sounds good to us and yeah
Duke we concur that all of the settings
are great we just want that pitch knob
in the lock position
okay
so to catch up on the procedures for
today
um koichiwakata
um did tighten some of the bolts on the
struts on the 1B side he's going to go
over and help Nicole Mann uh just for a
little bit they're gonna split up the
tasks on the 1A side Nicole Mann uh call
sign Duke is going to be continue to
work on that upper triangle which is the
top section of the full mounting
platform that's going to be installed on
the 1A Mass canister as part of today's
spacewalk in the meantime koichi bakara
over on the 1A work site they're over
there together now uh kawiji will work
on the continue to work on that foot
restraint
will enter later as part of accessing
those different parts of the mounting
platform so the two of them are over on
the 1A work site now
additional three that's four turns total
thank you
foreign
okay I need a tool it doesn't go all the
way
[Applause]
I'll get a tool Juke
[Applause]
yeah
I'll get it okay okay
Houston copies
yes
Izzy and I got two hand turns on m17
ready for PGT settings
copy two hand turns on m17 PGT settings
are Bravo One clockwise two
yeah
a firm you'll be going to torque we're
expecting a little over six turns to
nine turns
so that'll be about four or five to
seven turns additional to the two that
you got by hand and checking as well for
Blackline flush
because it's now it's locked on Tango
Tango and it's an opt-out in the can be
depressed
[Music]
[Applause]
all right koichi will have you Stow that
you can put tool back in the strut bag
and then you can assist Duke with that
copy that tools
you are the man
that Duke is the man
we love it
and
Luigi wakata able to uh work with that
uh pesky
um apfr the portable foot restraint now
the settings on that portable foot
restraint are complete so he'll join
Nicole man call sign Duke uh to continue
assembling that upper triangle of the
mounting platform that they're going to
install on the 1A Channel
foreign
flush and good torque with that you can
release the rep from the right upper
strut
foreign
[Music]
happy Duke
beautiful awareness of triangles just uh
above your head okay thank you
and I'll be with you
Houston copies
stalled covering the LT Thomas and the
Tipton installed on the grounding block
I'll have some more EGT settings for you
okay Duke
defense
put it off the spring is good
dude we got me
sounds good
I'm right there next to you to your
right coming I'm ready to help
okay
um
okay you can work on the mli and I'll
start working on the leftover struts
okay copy that
all right I'm gonna rotate back towards
you that's perfect all right
[Applause]
then I'm gonna work on this yeah
okay and heads up guys we've got about a
minute until a two minute loss so Duke
when you're ready I can give you PGT
settings and a couple steps to work on
okay go ahead
Bravo three clockwise too
I'm gonna do four turns on one fourth on
the next and then four thumbs back on
the original
yeah you got it and just check for black
light and flush on both of those once
you torque them
okay
sun rising on the International Space
Station as uh
Duke gets those
um pistol grip tool or the cordless
power drill settings
them working together is making the
build of that upper triangle of the
mounting platform a little bit easier
they were able to build the Handover we
are expecting flu's communication
um the just video and audio very briefly
soon
and right as expected we're losing video
and audio but we'll be regaining it
shortly we get good communication from
the tracking and data relate satellites
through an operation such as this the uh
um
though this is a larger Gap in
communication so you'll notice a lot of
folks in the room taking
a bio Break
um it is uh the gaps are relatively
short through a dynamic operation but
this is one of the longer ones so it
gives the team an opportunity uh to take
a break uh we'll get back to the action
pretty soon
while we're waiting to regain
communication from the International
Space Station let's go over the the plan
and the work for today so first of all
what they're doing is they're currently
on the 1A channel the channel that's
marked in the yellow there they are
constructing a modification kit uh four
future irosa solar arrays International
Space Station roll out solar arrays
there are four that are installed in the
International Space Station so far that
is all of the channels marked in blue
and then the green the mounting hardware
that that mounting platform was complete
uh but we saw koichiwakata tighten some
of the bolts on the struts to make sure
that that's ready to receive an irosa
later this summer
but the two of them now are over on the
1A Channel and they are working on the
modification kit now this is really a
modification to the original Mass
canister that's that uh light blue kind
of greenish Tin Can looking structure
that had a legacy solar arrays and they
are building that those struts that are
gonna house soon the International Space
Station roll out solar array on that
mounting bracket that you see there in
the graphics so they're building that
top portion right now the upper triangle
uh that requires a cordless power drill
to secure some of the bolts in place all
of these different components as you see
them now were transported through a bag
and that bag has been transported over
to their work site
um you can see some of the upper struts
some of those components they had to
take them out all of them are marked so
they know which pieces are which and
right now they are putting them together
to build the upper triangle this is not
the first time we've done it so we do
have Graphics from previous space walks
you can see there on the right that is a
fully constructed modification kit
that's what it looks like and then
here's a from a previous spacewalk to
space Walkers actually installing the
rollout solar arrays once it's installed
it unfolds just like you see there and
it's called a rollout solar array for a
reason it rolls out and covers uh the
bottom portion of the Legacy solar
arrays but it generates an incredible
amount of power and so far four have
been installed and are performing very
well so what they're doing now is
they're creating the um modification kit
for those another pair of solar arrays
that are going to be delivered to the
International Space Station later in the
summer we're now regaining video and
audio from the International Space
Station so let's go back to the action
where koichi and Duke are both
continuing to work on constructing uh
that modification kit
yeah I got 19 additional turns on M16
green light 18.3 on the truth and both
volts of Blackline flush okay 19
additional turns green light 18.3 and
both are Blackline flush
es okay
foreign
[Music]
thank you
for M15 did you do any hand turns to
start
um
two turn can't start followed by 19
turns with the PGT
s
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
copy Duke we're checking
[Applause]
[Applause]
over the buttons
I took a few
[Applause]
thanks for your patience guys for
chatting about M15
how come
okay Duke could we have you just check
the alignment tab is fully seated in
place
[Applause]
okay
sure
I'm at home
okay Duke we've got a great view of that
we concur with everything if you could
do us a favor and just hit M15 one more
time with the PGT
Bobby
hey just kidding Duke we're actually
happy with that bolt great news so you
can release the rep from the left upper
stretch
um
I'll do that
[Applause]
14 right
you got it
yeah the next bolts will be M13 and M14
and PGT settings should be the same
Bravo three clockwise too
I will reset clockwise
perfect [ __ ] upper is really
copy Duke
and koichi for you you'll be dropping
those approximately an additional 20
turns looking for torque good green
light and black on flush on both of
those
happy
[Applause]
I'm going to move the triangles with you
uh it's good
might be going on YouTube
[Applause]
I did say in 13 14 on the side
I see that okay all right
choose
three and uh level three clockwise
position on 20 turns
number 10.
19 and a half turns and uh got a green
light
18.5
the bounce 19.03 times
okay 19 and a half terms green light
18.5 on the torque
that's a good lead and that was on the
um
black line flush going to M14
copy and work
foreign
Duke's helmet camera we can very clearly
see the full build of the upper triangle
uh they've put uh two of the three
sections of the triangle together now
uh
the two of them working together
to install the final part of that with
Nicole Mann Duke able to hold one side
of the strut
um
koichiwakada has great access to
that uh final part of the upper strut
that's the right side of the upper
triangle
18 and a half turns visually confirmed I
got a green light
18.35
18.86 turns
[Applause]
okay
got it 18.5 turns green light 18 decimal
three torque and black line on both M13
and M14
okay with that we are happy with those
bolts you can tend the PGT back to the
strut bag and I think at this point Duke
will have you go ahead and Ingress the
apfr
koichi will have you go ahead and grab
the cables at this point
big picture for you both right now are
limiting consumable is going to be ev1
medox right now looking at about 640 645
tet we're just about 20 minutes down on
the timeline right now you guys are
doing good work
okay
all right crazy I'm all cleaned up I'm
headed over to the acfr okay
okay all right so with the upper
triangle built
um Duke has the upper triangle Tethered
to herself she'll be able to get into
the foot restraint that's already been
set up to allow her to access the top
part of the mass canister and get ready
to install that upper triangle in the
meantime
kuichiwakata working on the pistol grip
tool making sure that's going to be
stowed away and if you remember on the
way out to the work site koichiwakata
had a cable bag in tow and put it off to
the side to temporarily stow it he's
going to go ahead and access that cable
bag and grab some of the necessary
materials needed for continuing to build
this mounting platform next on the
timeline is uh now that the upper
triangle is built is to build that uh is
to build that right strut and a
correction that the triangle is actually
uh tethered uh not to um Duke okay
[Applause]
Duke for you as a reminder
no sudden movement on the mass canister
or mod kit
your lateral loads into the BGA avoid
cyclic lighting loading and donate
workforces into the mod kit before
they're fully installed
and Duke we also suggest Fair leading on
S4 handrail 2213 that's the inboard
radiator corner
foreign
cable
copy can we cheat that's perfect yep
you'll be going to the cable bag
grabbing the one alpha iosa cables
with the adjustable equipment tether I'm
showing on your brt
copy that
foreign
foreign
copy Duke
foreign
thing
copy Duke
hey I'm ready to uh one alpha Cable
Bundle and I'm gonna take it out
that's perfect we
could quit on your brt close the cable
bag and translate to the upper triangle
so this is a great shot of some of the
work that's being done concurrently
you can see uh ev2 Duke with the suit
with no Stripes uh is ingressing or
entering the portable foot restraint
that was set up for her to access uh
some of the parts that are needed to
install that upper triangle which
koichiwakata has in tow he went over to
that cable bag that he stowed early on
as he made his way out to the work site
grabbing some of the cables so he'll
have the upper triangle and the cables
in tow and one's uh Nicole Mann or Duke
is uh inside the portable foot restraint
and in a good configuration they'll do a
handoff so he'll be handing off some of
the components that she needs to to
construct the mounting platform one at a
time and they'll work together to
install this mounting platform
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
let me go there
okay okay there's nothing in my heels
there and I just want to make sure my
children
yeah left side is in and the right side
is uh yeah you're in the in the loop
okay
on the right side
that's right
further towards your
keep going
to put your
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
wakada has a great view
um he's eating uh Nicole man and guiding
her he's got a better view of where her
feet will go inside the portable foot
restraint
uh behind them you can see uh the Earth
the high definition views from the heca
camera are providing these beautiful
views of the Southern Atlantic Ocean
they just passed over the eastern border
of South America and they're heading on
a Northeastern track towards Africa but
they're over the South Atlantic Ocean
right now
in the correction that that upper
triangle is a specifically attached to
the um to the strut bag to the bag where
those the upper triangle components
actually came from but it will be
koichiwakata that will grab it and hand
it off to
radical man once she's in position
me
ant
so let's see my red one I feel like my
right one's in
yeah it looks like it okay I think I
need the heel a little more
foreign
the cameras here from the outside of the
International Space Station are zoomed
in on the portable Fortress
uh Duke through the process of getting
ingressed or fully integrated into that
portable Focus
right by the heel you come out to the
left
and he'll do your left
right to your left or see only to your
Left Foot Right Foot
okay and then go to the left the right
heel to your left side
that's good and stay there
okay thank you all right sure
you're good
great work guys
Duke all right
foreign
that's correct koichi you'll be
attaching the free hook of that
adjustable that's on the mounting
bracket already to the d-ring on the
adjustable going to the Cable Bundle
[Applause]
okay
Thomas
[Applause]
everyone
foreign
[Music]
copy koichi all right if that looks like
it's tidy enough to not get in Duke's
way we're happy with that config and you
can pass up the upper triangle if needed
you can also use those wire ties that
are already installed on the cables to
kind of tend it to the mounting bracket
okay what do you think I think
I'm sorry I can't really see it okay
whatever you think okay if I better come
up and then go in okay copy
and then I'll be with you
foreign
okay I'm coming from your right
let me know when you can grab any part
I think maybe if we bring it backwards
me a little bit
[Applause]
okay
okay
you have to rotate it
good words kuichi we see you looking
good just a reminder you don't need to
rep swap for this one we've got two
Redstone series
so right now uh koichiwakata you see in
the suit with red stripes he just handed
off the uh upper triangle too
awesome
Duke if it's easier you can lean back to
do that rolling motion or you can also
have koichi take control back
yeah let me get uh could you stay there
looks like that this table is
it okay just let me know when it's cool
okay stand by okay there
yeah so Duke has control of that upper
triangle Luigi just guiding her as she
needs to rotate it into position that's
appropriate for installing it on the
Mast canister
foreign
can we do uh
whether that's like a GoPro set up for
[Music]
oh yeah for you uh for both of you
actually right now just keep an eye on
those cables and make sure that they
don't get in the way or get snagged as
duke is trying to install the upper
triangle
okay
I'll keep that eye on it and then
end it here
next steps for you after that koichi
would be to move the silver PGT from the
strut bag to the whip X
happy
and then you'd be doing a socket swap on
your red PGT
uh thanks for the simple pdgwick
extender okay copy this over PGT is
moved and making sure that you have the
oh no not yet oh copy not yet not yet uh
Z Mac okay I'm gonna move it now
perfect gotcha
foreign
three
nice work do you if you need to lean
back at all to get enough clearance for
that maneuver I know you're working in a
tight workspace there
all right got it awesome great job
kuichi for that PPT just a reminder to
move the bag rat with the PGT you'll be
using that rat for the with X handrail
yeah thanks and I heard the bad rats and
the PGT and now it's attached to the
music extender
nice okay now the silver bgt is attached
are you in kuichi you'll be doing a
socket swap on your red PGT
6 inch wobble that's in your trash bag
now we'll take a good pull test
do that
we work
and Duke looks like you're in a big
mistake you'll make sure that that arrow
is pointing up
and then install the center pad canister
with the left side first then press in
on the right side to engage the soft
dock
okay
right but I don't think it went all the
way in but
copy great work I'll have PGT settings
for you next let me know when you're
ready
so with a little bit of finagling and
getting the upper triangle into the
right rotation Duke has successfully
soft docked it to the upper part of the
mass canister uh that's the point where
the upper triangle is to be installed
so the next steps will be to use that uh
hand to drill the cordless power drill
to secure it in place with a few bolts
PC settings are alpha two clockwise too
you'll be driving M5 six seven and eight
approximately two turns each any order
two turns each
okay Gina attendance up in complete 7 16
16 trouble is on my red Infinity
installed was a good pull test on your
PGT
through
okay copy two turns on M5 six seven and
eight you'll now be going to torque on
each of these in any order an additional
three to eight turns or so
koichi we're a little down on the
timeline still today now is when we had
planned to install the mut with GoPro uh
we'll leave it up to you but if might be
the kind of thing that you would want to
defer or do without up to you
okay what do you think
3.6 uh on the torque
copy additional five turns off five 3.6
on the torque
I've got three boats left here and then
I'll be ready for the the left lip
stretch so I'll leave that up to you
later where you're at okay uh if I have
a few minutes
that I can do
okay okay let's do that
four turns green light 3.8 on the torque
M8 copy four turns 3.8 green light on M8
3.9 on the torque M6
copy four and a half 3.9 green light on
M6
and koichi for you we do think you have
time totally up to you no pressure you'd
be for the plan installing that mutt end
effector on handrail two two one four
that's the inboard Edge middle handrails
okay copy that
four turns green light 3.7 torque M7
copy four additional turns 3.7 green
light on M7
okay Duke those are good bolts all four
of them you can release the mounting
bracket Rhett and next you'll check that
the center pad Moi and fit pins are
still installed
okay
copy that's great you can rotate the
upper triangle down for later access
after you have the rep released
and then from both of you we'll take a
good glove half and Gauntlet check
and the happy stay friends
don't let the cover before you do
copy you both
with that the upper triangle has been
installed onto the 1A Mass canister
pick up popping out
and adjusting the uh apfr
big picture
okay copy yeah that's what we're waiting
on is just that uh mounting bracket
Rhett
I think I'll get that right after I get
maybe ready pfr rolled over or once I
pop out
yeah we're happy with that plan Duke
with that you can egress the apfr you'll
be also socket swapping to the two inch
rigid that's in your trash bag with a
good pull test and then adjusting the
with x
so the upper triangle is installed
you'll hear the periodic uh glove and
half checks with the glove just to make
sure there are no Nicks or scrapes and
make sure they're in good quality to
continue working on the spacewalk and
then the half is the helmet absorption
pad just a quick field test to see if
there's any liquid or water everything
looks good so we'll hear those checks
periodically that rent is a retractable
tether that's the one that was anchoring
the um upper triangle to the strut bag
so uh Duke has to release that and then
they can move on to the next task she's
going to be exiting the foot restraint
here shortly
foreign
[Applause]
the Jaws are out on that end effector
it's locked and then I see
yeah uh yoga out and it's locked
[Applause]
copy that sounds like a good config
all right so Duke is
egressing the apfr and then we'll have
you work together on the apfr and with x
reconfig
ures so happy that I got ingressed it
does not want to let me go
okay
[Applause]
we copy that Duke and koichi once you
get over there you can uh help her if
that is useful looks like you need to
just rotate your heels a little further
in I know that's tricky with just an
Ingress Aid
okay
thank you sure
[Applause]
[Applause]
maybe give it a tick
okay
[Music]
okay right here
so right now koiji wakada is helping uh
Nicole Mann consign Duke to egress or
get out of the foot restraint
um that foot restraint was configured
such that it gave her just the right
angle to um install that upper triangle
it was the right angle for her to use
that cordless power drill to PGT pistol
grip tool and then drive to those bolts
uh she needs to get out they're going to
reconfigure it uh angle it a different
way so now and then she'll get back in
it so she'll be able to access the next
set of bolts for when they install that
next component of the mounting platform
which is the right strut so they'll work
through that methodically getting her
out re-angling it back in and then
they'll get the new component of the
mounting bracket from the strut bag uh
hand it off and then bolt that uh to the
mask canister
right
[Applause]
I'm gonna get this right off can we see
that ceremony bracket
Houston guys
so we're in another Handover period
again we're receiving video and audio
from the geosynchronous uh tedris
satellites tracking and data relay
satellites um another intermittent Gap
will be regaining video and audio here
shortly as a quick recap the two have
completed the installation of the upper
triangle on the 1 8 power Channel there
are several components that make up the
mounting bracket so that's done uh and
they're currently trying to reposition
the foot restraint to get a new angle
and allow Nicole Mann coal sign Duke to
access the next part of the installation
which is the bolts that will attach the
right strut to the upper triangle
foreign
's back with you after a quick Handover
and koichi
that sounds like a good plan we've got
you adjusting the apfr but if you want
to coordinate who does apfr who does
with X that's fine by me
okay I'm doing the Olympic Fender and
that Duke will do the uh if you're far
the soccer swap right now okay
copy working on the socket swap for you
duke
and big picture update for you both
right now we're looking at about 30
minutes down on the timeline our
limiting consumable is still ev1 medox
but up to about six hours 50 minutes and
we'd love your input on just how you're
doing and how you feel about that big
picture update
are you feeling good uh feeling good
yeah okay sounds good continue
great work you guys are doing awesome so
far
[Applause]
a good read from the crew you heard
they're a little bit behind on the
timeline but still making good progress
to get this mounting bracket installed
both of them are taking two different
parts of the foot restraint right now to
configure it for that next setting
study with X adjusted to extension of
one that's perfect
and I'll have apfr settings you're ready
it's going to be a roll to the right
go to the right okay
that's correct yeah we'll be adjusting
both the roll and the pitch going to
Papa Papa Charlie
first I'm gonna hit okay yeah
let me know if I'm pulling on you I can
no no you're not pulling yourself
so that's a yo
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
Glory Kelly and I'm gonna change the
[ __ ]
but I have to use the tool
he's two copies you can certainly grab
Lucas's Perfect Tour if you need it
you need it
36 inches off with a good pull test
copy a good pull test
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I can help you
okay let me just set my PGT and started
[Applause]
great teamwork guys and just a reminder
to watch out for each other's hands
there are a lot of a lot of pinch points
in there
oh okay I was able to unlock it
nice work Luigi
all right so
I'm gonna take the pitch Duke now if it
was very I had to hold on to the uh
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
positions okay
[Music]
you can also try using the boots
you can try using the boot plate to get
a little bit more of a lever armor
just doesn't move
back up so that we can use it okay yeah
let's do that because we roll it back
yeah
upset position
foreign
[Applause]
a little bit
and then we can pull on the fruit plates
on your face
okay
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
yeah that's what we expect we know this
is a really sticky pitch apfr
yeah it doesn't move
I'm not focusing I don't know if you can
see it
but yeah we see that standby will uh
possible suggestions for you guys
so
therefore when I say that I used a good
place to have a little bit more of an
arm maybe we um I hold on to the Tulips
so if I work at the roof right all the
way around would that help but it was
like a smooth squeeze yeah
I'm stuck it was sticky the whole time
yeah let's try that so in order to do
that do you need to roll 90 degrees
because I don't know can you grab onto
here where the fuels go
like if you can grab onto that heel
then we'll go down to some smooth motion
down
all right
shall we just move
it's
let's do that motion
like fish on the front okay
foreign
[Music]
as you need in order to get the boot
plate in a better position for leverage
and just a reminder to avoid using the
glove for a pounding motion like that
poker
okay
it moved a little bit but now it's stuck
in that position
a couple more
[Music]
yeah it doesn't
Okay so
what else can we do here I wonder if we
can use the moving armor
maybe you can pull I got nothing to
really react against here okay then let
me try that
but if you can get your hand on it yeah
Duke you can definitely pull on the
Ingress Aid if that helps get some more
leverage
okay
we're pulling from the English league
because it's moving it's moving okay so
we're halfway between X and R okay
two more notches
great work guys and as long as you can
get it to at least here at Sierra we can
give you some alternate settings
yeah I think maybe
all right
this is a small amount more
videos
I need to
foreign
[Applause]
all right
good idea dude that was sad
to hold on to the uh
everything looks good
okay yeah
papa papa
amazing great work guys
all right and just to make sure you're
still in Charlie on the roll as well
[Music]
okay
okay
all right
okay
okay
thank you awesome great work and also
take these other completely
yeah if you could check 12 on the Yas
there's also that rep for the mounting
bracket is underneath your right arm I'm
going to go release that right now
though squeaky I don't think you'll be
Tangled but it's just underneath your
right arm
okay you're good you're clear yeah I
think so there's a good and then you
always getting back uh yeah okay
copy and concur really good work guys
next steps for you will be to get the
right mid Struts from straps 12 and 13
and Duke will be ingressing the apfr
Bobby Bobby
and we'll take a glove check from both
of you
okay uh if you run gloves
copy guiji
copy Duke
hey Billy
with the right strut right
copyright mid is released
once Duke has Ingress you'll be passing
that off to her and then getting the
right lower strut from straps seven and
eight
copy
copy that so a quick recap it did take a
little bit of work but the duo did get
the portable foot restraint to the angle
it needs to be to install that next
section the right strut so koichiwakata
is going to get that and hand it off to
Nicole Mann once she gets back into the
foot restraint and at the right angle to
access the bolts that she'll need to
drive to install that right strut
foreign
and a reminder also we've got that red
attached to the upper triangle still
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
like that
is almost there yeah yeah
right side is the position of this game
you can go a little bit forward
yeah almost like a little bit to your
right on the right foot
right okay
let me go there
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah position is great okay that's good
yeah okay and then sit down heel down
heel down for that because you slide the
your left foot okay so you've got it
inside now you can slide
right right to your left
[Applause]
the last weekend
so you need to put your you know toe a
little bit forward a little bit further
yeah
to your left
turn you down feel down
peel down heel to your right a little
bit
heel to your right a little bit okay
give me one sec let me get my right in
the toilet okay
left foot uh heel to your right a little
bit
that's good that's good
okay you're in
[Applause]
more to your left
you're in do you feel it
yeah okay
okay copy that
all right man we'll come back and can do
the uh extract okay I have the mounting
bracket red
okay
you want to release it yeah are you
ready for it yeah I'm ready okay there
it is
okay
all right
it's released
let me go back to a different position
or head off okay
at the moment
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
experience
okay let's shut you
and that you want to have the attack
side right
yeah here we go can you see it
[Music]
um
controls
[Music]
quickly have my brt rat okay uh
um
[Music]
okay
all right
and the next one is the lower shot all
right yeah
that's correct and you'll be passing the
clevis end toward ev2
okay so you know that's from the strap
eight and seven correct
a firm strap seven and eight
okay copy
and then Duke you'll want to ret to the
handrail stanchion that's nearest the
Columbus
foreign
foreign
controls
okay
just stand by okay oh standby here
right you can release your rest okay
that's a bad red too
it's a moment
stay there
okay
okay
I'm gonna translate to the uh
yeah Luigi that's right you'll be
translating to the right sub spherical
bearing on the mass canister right side
and just report to us the spherical
bearing alignment
then you'll be grabbing the silver PGT
from that with xanro
once guichi gets down there you'll be
helping out with the lower strut
alignment and you'll work together to
install
it looks good
copy quiche you can grab the story
foreign
just a big picture update here right now
we're looking at probably between 45
minutes and an hour down on the timeline
just thanks to that sticky pitch on the
apfr so right now we are thinking that
the get ahead the S6 cdcu jumper and one
Bravo cable routing are going to be
saved for a future Eva but we're still
in good shape just keep doing what
you're doing you guys are doing great
work
foreign
clockwise one
foreign
Mann working at the two ends of the
lower strut this uh attaches the top of
the mounting bracket which is part of
that upper triangle that they built
earlier and the strut uh anchors it to
the lower part of the Mast canister and
this is on the right side so koichi
wakada because he's not in the foot
restraint will have access to that
bottom part and he'll use his pistol
grip tool to Anchor it to the bottom
part of the Mask canister while Nicole
man Duke um with who is still in the
portable foot restraint has access uh to
the top portion of this lower strut
which is being attached to the front end
of that mounting bracket
okay
tracking Alpha One clockwise one
now with Duke's house that you'll be
aligning the lower stretch
and we're just looking to start with
four turns on m19
hit me up that we had to keep down here
and then I walk on the four turns
copy that's great and if you get any uh
hand turns on that bolt just let us know
and a reminder while you're down there
to watch your fingers there's a point
there between the lower strut pad to the
VGA
okay copy that
okay dude I'm ready to receive it
okay
[Music]
that's right that's good
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
doesn't align well
if you could can you
click hand over here can you move up to
your right a little bit to your right
[Applause]
that's good
we're in a short uh Handover period
right now so we still have audio from
the International Space Station we can
hear the crew but we'll be getting video
back shortly
[Applause]
okay
great feel free to hand start that
koichi we'll be back in a couple seconds
this one up here
we're back with you after a Handover and
any turns that you put on that m19 bolt
let us know
guppy four turns on m19 great work new
PGT settings for you koichi Bravo 7
clockwise II and Duke now that m19 has
started clockwise too
good read back
Duke you can start M20
that's the right lower strut L6 to the
mounting bracket check that the pit pin
lanyard is free of the clevis and I'll
have PGT settings for you when you're
ready
okay
then clockwise
uh so stand by until Duke has her end
started but you will be going to torque
on this one we're expecting 10 and a
half to 11 turns once Duke's end is
starting
it's in his career I've got one for an
answer
probably one tournament started
your PGT settings do are Bravo One
clockwise two
and this will be about one extra turn on
M20
just one extra we're looking for about
two total here
reflection total okay sorry I should
have gone off my hand but
yeah that's my bad I couldn't help yeah
in 19 10.5 to 11 turns once you get
started
I got a problem
here's a good shot of the two astronauts
working on both ends of that lower right
strut so you see Nicole Mann is in the
foot restraint she's got access to the
top part of the lower strut that's
towards the upper triangle uh she's got
a pistol grip tool to secure that to the
top portion and then
koichiwakata at the bottom portion
securing the lower strut to the base of
the mass canister
you can drive m19 to torque expecting
ten and a half to 11 additional turns
looking for green light and torque
readings
copy that teamwork 10.5 to 11 turns on
m19
good read back
and Duke once you've got your PGT stowed
we can have you start on the one alpha
right irosa cable routing
cool
okay uh
FEMA on m19 I got a green light they
talked about the
25.9 2000 and uh
and the blockline Flash uh
I see a little bit of a jack
it's almost there but
[Music]
um
yeah I don't know if you can see it on
the hacker Luigi we are expecting to
finish this off with the torque wrench
but we copied green light 25.9 torque
and was that 10 turns
39.6
so visually
copy that
all right with that koichi you can grab
the torque wrench from the right lower
strut and you'll socket swap to the two
inch rigid from the PGT to the torque
wrench with a good pull test
puppy
Duke for you you'll remove the short
wire tie securing the one alpha right
irosa cables to the mounting bracket
and Stow them in your trash bag if they
were used
and then you'll release the long Wi-Fi
on the cables
just one Twist on the one alpha right
side wire tie
so from this uh helmet camera view we're
looking from the vantage point of duke
or NASA astronautical man you can see
koichiwakata working on the base of the
lower strut Cole man working on the on
the cables of course the strut is really
a support structure that allows the
irosa the International Space Station
roll out solar array to be installed but
it does need to provide Power ultimately
to the International Space Station so
these cables uh will be uh positioned
accordingly so that when the irosa is
installed on the mounting bracket that
uh they'll be able to basically hook it
up to the International Space Station
and the power that would be drawn from
the new solar arrays can be sent to all
of the appropriate Downstream places uh
on the International Space Station so
they're positioning those cables now so
when they later uh install the irosas
right now we're looking at uh this
summer to get the iroses up to the space
station and installed uh that they'll be
able to hook it up 15 turns with this
torque wrench until you break over two
times
[Applause]
that looks really good
you'll next be driving M20 to torque
after koichi finishes his m19 end
ing
checking
foreign
we actually need 14 to 15 total turns so
you only have about another turn and a
half to go much better news
that's good to know that's good to know
thank you yes sorry
that was a great release thank you yeah
that was about to be tough times
foreign
stop it
okay I felt the two breakovers and
Visually come from two breakovers from
m19
next we'll take a check that the black
line is parallel to the cylinder and
flush there's no gap between the strap
loss and bearing and there's no movement
with the wheels
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how many additional turns was that with
the torque wrench
method
around quarters
copy additional quarter turn
between
between the halftime
okay
we'll be uh checking that real quick
it's a little less than we were
expecting
okay good news we're good with that bolt
kuichi and we'll take that one last
wiggle test there
okay
okay
no motion
perfect with that you can socket swap
to the two intrigid from your torque
wrench back to the silver PGT with a
good pull test
and you can relocate the torque wrench
to the silver PGT you'll keep that rep
from the strut with the torque wrench
Duke once you have that pit pin
installed you can go back and drive M20
to torque we're expecting five to seven
additional turns looking for Blackline
flush
copy
green light 11.9 on the torque
copy six turns 11.9 on the torque green
light check blockline flush
copy juice
okay copy can we cheat check the lower
strut mli is covering the strut pad Duke
you can store your PGT
okay
the 19 area
Scotty on the bed great work Luigi you
can translate to the side pad location
on the right side there
okay uh before that I will practice the
yes to the silver PPT
good words
once you start your PGT you can release
the rat from the lower struts and then
with that grounding pip pin installed
you can install the mli over the lower
strut Clevis
I think
and after that you'll be working on the
right mid strip
koichi you may also want to tend that
PGT over to the other side so you can
easily reach it once you get over there
okay
okay great
attention
and I'm gonna translate to the other
side
and Duke for you also just makes sure
that the rat has been released from the
lower stretch
copy thanks
for those following along the duo are
now wrapping up after uh successfully uh
driving the bolts to install the lower
right strut so they're just doing some
cleanup work right now and just making
sure the multi-layer insulation is
covering uh the parts that they were
working on and they're going to now grab
the next component for installation
which is the middle strut here's a
graphic you can see the lower strut on
the right of this graphic that's the one
they just installed the mid strut goes
really to the middle of the mass
canister that's coming up next getting
in place to install the side pad on that
mass canister
okay
copy that
and Gucci once you're in place I can
preemptively give you some PGT settings
for those bolts
okay
okay MRI is on M20 and I'm going to get
the uh mixture
great work Duke
so uh again I can translate on this uh
[Music]
to go out to the
midstrap area
hey from Gucci
foreign
brt here
yep one squeegee's in a good position to
receive I think you will pass that mid
strut with the side pad toward koichi
hey thank you for waiting
[Applause]
um
running on your right yeah
all right keep coming
nice work guys
koichi as you received it just check
that the arrow is pointing up and you'll
ultimately be engaging the left side
first and then pressing in on the right
side
arrow is up
and engaging website first
and then right side is it
great job
when you're ready I'll have PGT settings
for you and we're coming up on a quick
Handover in about two minutes I'll keep
you posted
okay I'm ready to copy the PGT settings
clockwise two
okay
ah
and Duke Eye will also have PGT settings
for you once you're ready
okay I think I'll start with the um
copy no problem
here our next steps
exactly you'll be waiting on him to
start two turns on M9 through M12 but
then you will go to torque on M24
great copy
okay that the clockwise two sets for at
19 to 12.
those are good words koichi you can go
ahead and start
okay
two on M9
three
foreign
as a refresher we're currently
installing the mid strut on the right
side for this mounting platform
koichiwakata was working on the mass
canister side so if you see the side pad
on the right from this graphic he's
working on driving the bolts on that
side
Nicole Mann call sign Duke is still in
the portable foot restraint she's on the
right side so she'll be soon driving the
bolts over there to attach the mid strut
to the mounting platform I need to go
back to I think two two put it back
so you like me to put it back in so we I
could try to talk you off to it
we're together to get it back on okay
yeah all right
um
all the way
back
to get the correct original orientation
checking Duke
but if you pull in front of you in the
kind of the correct orientation then
I'll help you kind of fly it in
I don't see I really don't see the
no and I haven't lined up like in the
correct orientation
all right people do not see any
interface
okay don't need to rotate
and that's towards you he said rotate
down 90 degrees
hey guys our recommendation
koichi if you have a decent reach to put
two additional turns on the rest of
those bolts M10 11 and 12 without your
brt go ahead and do that and then we can
have Duke put two turns on her end and
come help you with the brt
after that we'll get to Dukes for the
VIP
so I'm working on M10 for two terms
two turns on 10 times 11.
11
thank you
complete
copy quiche
okay I'm 12.
10 complete
okay copy koichi
with that Duke you can go ahead and put
a couple turns on your end
foreign
just have you go to torque as planned so
your PGT settings are going to be Bravo
One clockwise 2.
50
[Music]
[Music]
6 stand by kuichi if you can let's have
you go to Twitter since this is an alpha
setting on your PGT
so we're expecting an additional I can
do that yeah more than three additional
turns on these expecting five to ten
turns total on M9 10 11 and 12.
okay
copy Duke you'll be going about six and
a half to nine turns on M24 looking for
blockline flush
so once again the two astronauts working
in tandem
left side you see her driving the bolts
towards the bracket and then back
together so we want to just run the
procedure and then we'll have koichi
come to Duke
in order to work together for his brt
copy that probably seven and a half
turns green light 11.8 on the torch
copy seven and a half turns 11.8 on the
torque green light looking for Blackline
flush
copy Duke you can Stow your PGT and
install the mid-strip pin into the
grounding block on the mounting bracket
foreign
talk from 9 through 12. yeah affirm your
go to do that koichi M9 through M12
okay
clockwise too and uh excuse me for your
property times good settings and it'll
be more than three additional turns
we're looking for five to ten total
going to torque
I'll do that work
s
perfect you can install the mli over M13
and M14 check that the mounting bracket
upper surface is clear
after that we'll take a glove happening
3.6 copy four additional turns green
light 3.6 on the torque for M9
are we working on
president I'm gonna have to hit that mli
when I do the uh
copy Duke no problem we'll take a glove
hap and Gauntlet check
happy five turns 7.8 foot-pounds green
light and which bolt was that quiche
puppy M10 thank you
okay
working on the M11 now
covers
copy Duke thanks
five and a half thirds complete 46 sit
down I gotta agree like something five
and a half additional green light 3.6 on
M11
working on themselves
Duke next steps for you will be to the
four thirds complete
copies on M12 3.6 sit down
copy four turns green light 3.6 on m12s
and for Duke you can egress the apfr and
then we'll have you work to roll the
apfr
I think I need to get the uh
checking Duke
might be a few events
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah Duke if you can reach that
uh you can release the Rhett from that
one but we're assuming you're probably
not going to be able to reach it so
that'll be a step for koichi once he
does a cgt which Gucci you can do now
okay uh say again
Luigi can Stow your PGT
um and next release the red Duke's rat
from the midstret
okay copy that
is
okay I'm ready all right here we go okay
I got it okay it's released
so with that that uh completes driving
the bolts on the mint strut on the right
side now the two will work to um make
sure the multi-layer insulation that
white cover is secured
um Duke has to go ahead to get out of
the foot restraint and start working on
re-angling it so they can work on the
left side they're going to do the same
thing so they're going to start with the
lower strut that goes to the base of the
mass canister and then complete the mid
strut they'll just do the same thing
really on the opposite side of the mass
canister but they're just wrapping up
the work on the mid strut as we speak
with that we'll take the glove happen
Gauntlet check from you
okay uh
what the food then I have been
Duffy and I see your gauntlets are down
and do some pictures when you're ready
to egress that apfr we'll have you roll
to access the left side
okay
[Music]
perfect this is going to be roll of
hotel
meanwhile can I go back to the stretch
bag
a firm kuichi and take your brt with you
see that
last weekend you come down here
we're safe together I think it might be
Tangled on my legs so we need to take a
look at that
okay let me check that
all right calm down now we'll take a
look
s like okay
and hey just for your your essay we've
got a really good camera view here those
cables were snagging on the Ingress head
but it looks like it's clear now
thank you
okay
firm Hotel
okay hotel is set
copy and I think now is a good time to
work on the brt
sounds good so uh
let me local here
that's a good position there yeah is it
good yeah
foreign
guys before you fully install that brt
we've got the d-ring extender going
through the loop of the brt so just make
sure that that's clear
um
and
I think it'll be easy to clean once he
releases the DLC from his uh totally
that's a good plan
that's great okay
okay
right
if I can lock it and give it a filter
okay it doesn't look flush just to
confirm what you said Duke
is that it's lost
and I'm giving it a good pull test
so
okay
gotta make sure that's expected yeah
I didn't see it I didn't get a good view
of the Gap but if you've got the tab up
and a good pull test
I think that's likely a good config let
me confirm
okay
yeah ground is happy with that I think
yeah and yeah now might be a good time
to just get the brt on the correct side
of the d-ring center
okay so just you just really
foreign
nice work guys
look at the other the other side
perfect thank you
thank you duke
okay
so we can continue with the exactly
that's right so next steps will be
getting the left mid strut from straps
nine and ten Gucci you'll pass that left
mid straight to Duke
hey
and guys big picture uh we've got a
small win in that the medox limiting
reagent is continuing to look better and
better so we're looking at about a pet
of seven hours now as they're limiting
consumable we're still about 45 minutes
to an hour down on the timeline so no
changes there since the last update
for you
this is the I need the um
yeah this is the right one okay let me
go all right let me get back over
periodically throughout the spacewalk
you'll hear reports of limiting
consumables of course the spacesuits
have uh the portable life support so
it's all contained within the spacesuit
and they measure these limiting
consumables but that medox that's
referred to as the carbon scrubbing
capability uh every time the crew
members exhale there is a system that is
currently pulling that carbon dioxide
from the environment inside the suit
it's trending in a good direction which
means that if needed the crew members
can use a little extra time at the back
end of this spacewalk up to seven hours
total uh for the duration of the
spacewalk if needed
oh
flower strap next A-frame left lower
from strap
and then Duke you can Ingress the API
once that's stored on your brt
looks like we did a set of still right
above your head here okay I'm gonna get
it out of your way okay
stop you both and of course feel free to
use some teamwork for apfr Ingress which
you can leave that partially stowed in
the strut bag if that helps tend it
while it gets in the apfr
okay copy that
are you ready
[Music]
okay I'm on my brt
uh
let me go through that yeah
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
forward
and then that's good and the website
position is good
that's right okay
good keep going keep going forward yeah
that's good
okay that right side position yeah
forward go forward okay and now we can
slide both heels
okay now left heel down further down
[Applause]
your left heel to your left
foreign
we're getting a great view from the high
definition helmet camera of koichiwakata
who's guiding uh his space walking
crewmate Nicole Mann call sign Duke
through the Ingress process of the apfr
the um portable foot restraint and so
we're seeing up close how the heels
actually Ingress into the uh portable
foot restraint for to lock uh the
astronaut into place so that they can
access the work site
foreign
awesome teamwork guys looking really
good
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to the handrail nearest the Clevis
foreign
there's that handoff we're really just
repeating the process that we saw on the
other side
on the right side we're repeating the
same process on the left lower strut
first
and secure it with bolts to the mounting
bracket that you see from the view of
Duke's helmet camera and then from
koichi's he'll he'll install the lower
bracket on the base of the mass canister
so that'll be the first steps same thing
we saw on the right side we're doing
them you can translate to the left side
spherical bearing
copy that
you'll be going outboard and then across
the iea via the PVR GF handrails and we
recommend Fair leading to keep your
tether off of the BGA
understand
the long translation there okay
copy
Duke I can give you PGT settings for
when you are eventually driving the M22
bolts
[Applause]
okay go ahead
that'll be Bravo One clockwise two
sister for this one once you started I
start mine and then I have to wait for
it before I fourth grade
yeah that's exactly right so he'll start
his okay you're about two turns wait for
him to twerk and then you can twerk
foreign
great work koichi when you get there
we'll be looking for the left sub
spherical bearing alignment
and Duke just to start thinking about it
in between those first two turns that
you put on M22 and then while you're
waiting for koichi's bolts to be torqued
you can start the left side aerosa cable
routing
okay
okay
at first I don't have I don't cross the
state each other with yours that's okay
you gotta do not trust that should be
okay right yeah
um
I went around the grandpa fixture side
so
it's still clear from VGA and from uh
right okay so I'm gonna continue as long
as it's off the BGA we're happy
great great
okay I have to go down
foreign
foreign
to work on those that lower left strut
you can see uh Duke in place ingressed
into the foot of strain ready to go as
soon as koichiwakata gets into place
we're now entering a uh Handover so
we're losing Communications temporarily
and we will look at it soon we're also
entering into an orbital night time so
you saw sort of the the lighting change
just a bit
um depending on the length of this
Handover we might come back into an
orbital night time in which case we'll
have the external lights on the outside
of the space station being Illuminating
their work site and then of course the
helmet cameras on the or the helmets on
the spacesuits themselves have lighting
that allow
the duo to continue their work
installing these struts there are no
lighting or thermal constraints when it
comes to the installation process
sometimes astronauts have to pause
during various lighting and thermal
conditions depending on the work that
they're doing but we'll see Duke and
koichi together continuing the process
non-stop through their installing this
Mudkip
okay copy that koichi just to confirm
the soft spherical bearing had a good
alignment
um
perfect and for that M21 end you can
hand start that or I can give you PGT
settings with the silver PGT from the
with X handle
okay uh could you give me the pgp
settings
that'll be Alpha One clockwise one and
looking for approximately four turns
oh
okay Alpha One clockwise one quarter
good read back
foreign
foreign
down
hey there
[Applause]
okay you got it okay yeah I got it okay
yeah keep coming
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
foreign
guppy four turns complete and that's
right Duke you can start complete
copy that guichi and Duke before you
start M22 just make sure the pit pin
lanyard is free of the Clevis
then you can hand start or PGT you're
just starting with two turns
all right
[Applause]
foreign
copy both of you koichi it'll be Bravo 7
clockwise tune but as you know we are
waiting for M21 to be driven two turns
before you can start
copy that
level seven clockwise too
copy Bravo One clockwise 2 set
and two turns on M22 so with that koichi
you can drive M21 to torque this will be
an additional 10 and a half dollars
yet copy Duke thank you okay
puppy
so uh Duke Nicole Mann is
22. copy two turns and just to make sure
do you have the pit pin clear of the
Clevis
America
copy okay now kuichi you can go this is
10 and a half to 11 turns going to
torque on M21
so recap the two astronauts are on two
ends of the lower strut Nicole Mann
towards the mounting bracket she's got
the pistol grip tool so she can secure
it to the mounting bracket and again
koichiwakata is at the base of the mass
canister at the other end of that strut
also with his own pistol grip tool so
they're just bolting both sides of the
strut to make sure it's secured in place
it's going to go at the lower strut on
the left and then they'll work together
on the mid strut next with three twists
happy
birthday
okay y'all
then I got the
icons and then I got a green light but
the
different uh far away from the uh
okay copy five turns we are expecting to
use the torque wrench for this
so you'll be swapping the two inch rigid
from the silver PGT to the torque wrench
with a good pull test and then we'll
continue driving M21
okay
but you know it's uh you know it's not
on the right side
when I told that I was on the uh
PGT it was pretty close to the blocking
flash black line clutch but now I see uh
for in order to get the black line
Flagship discovery about the
uh
one third of an inch that you could be
dreaming by token so I don't think we'll
get there
yeah copy standby
yeah koichi we will have you switch to
the torque wrench it will get there all
the way with the torque wrench I know
that's going to take uh more turns if
you want to stand by just a moment let
me ask and see if we can make another
plan okay copy that
okay copy that
all right Gucci uh we will have you
switch to the torque wrench
um so we're expecting more turns than
you had to do on the other side okay
but this will get us to the correct
torque and focus alignment with that
bearing copy that so switch the two inch
rigid to the torque wrench with a good
pull test okay copy that
copy that okay
you know I've got the uh wrap cable for
the left um
two three twists really nice work Duke
that's great and now once we've got M21
to torque with the torque wrench you'll
be back at M22 so stand by for M21
dude you can also go ahead and install
that grounding pit pin into the
grounding block on the mounting bracket
and stuff
copy
okay okay
Happy People tests
next you'll drive M21 to torque with
that torque wrench going to full torque
so that the torque wrench breaks over
twice
it's 14 to 15 turns total so we're
expecting nine or ten additional turns
with the torque wrench
godspeed I know that's a lot of turns
as a quick overview of installing these
struts um with the astronauts at both
ends of the strut they alternate driving
the bolts so it was
um
koichi wakada who started with his
pistol grip tool once he was done and
went back to Nicole Mann now it's back
to koichiwakada and then Nicole man will
do it again there's only one bolt but
they just addressed that same bolt two
times while alternating part of the
procedure is to just make to avoid
anything like stripping or or anything
like that so right now you see
koichiwakata using that torque wrench
and that's really just to make sure it's
super secure he's also going to do a
pool test just a quick tug just to make
sure there's no wiggle and it's truly
installed and so they'll continue to
alternate Nicole man has one more one
more time has to address that bolt on
the on the top side next to the mounting
bracket and then they'll wrap up with
the multi-layer insulation making sure
it looks good before getting to the left
mid strut and that'll be the last
component of the um of installing the
mounting bracket before they go around
and secure the mli and address any last
minute items but that's the last
component needed for installation
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
Mercury
and Medina
a little broken there will you say again
the turn
and twice uh break over twice and then
the vehicle twice
foreign
[Music]
okay copy black line flush and the
torque wrench broke over twice we'll
look for no gap between the strut boss
and bearing and a good wiggle test and I
was unable to copy the total number of
additional turns that you added
chance with the uh that's okay
and the circle bearing
okay kuichi we hear you see a gap
between the Boston bearing and copied
five turns
okay kuichi stand by one while we talk
about that
puppy
right now both of the astronauts just
pausing taking a moment to relax as they
wait for ground teams to assess their
work with the bolts on this particular
lower strut
determining if it's the if it was
appropriate for and if the
mounting bracket itself and the mounting
platform really is in a good
configuration before they proceed on to
the next steps
okay koichi we've talked it over um I
know you will love this you get to use
the torque wrench even more what we're
going to have you do is continue going
until the torque wrench breaks over and
then keep going so this will add extra
torque see if you can get that bolt to
move any further and just keep us posted
okay so uh it will break over at 60
pounds and then I can I keep talking hey
firm yep it's gonna break over and as it
breaks over just keep applying it torque
I'll do that
koichi ideally we're looking for one
additional turn let us know if it starts
to move at all
okay
and meanwhile Duke we're checking to see
if you can start M22 in this
configuration but stand by for now
Duke you will be able to starch this M22
driving M22 to torque that'll be an
additional five to seven turns you
should have that PGT set to Bravo 1.2
already looking for Blackline blush
thank you
we're watching your camera view here it
looks like it's not moving and you apply
more torque is that correct
yeah it doesn't have any sign of voting
foreign
okay copy six and a half turns green
light 11.9 on the torque for M22
Duke
we also want black line flush after that
you can store your PGT
and then koichi we didn't have a great
view of that uh boss and boss bearing
just to make sure
um if you can take another look at it
see if you can get eyes on I know it's
dark and make sure that we're looking at
the boss to boss bearing clearance as
opposed to the pad itself from structure
and also take a wiggle test
okay
[Applause]
do you have a heck of you now
we don't have a great view of it so
we'll trust your uh eyes in person there
and just looking for the gap between the
Boston bearings
just looking at the view
uh there's no change in the last uh you
know attempt you know I told you down to
the you know the breaking towards value
and
as a matter of fact
with this uh you know helmet right I
really do not see the um
[Music]
the vehicle bearing side because the
circle bearing is not going to Black and
it's uh
[Music]
to the uh
Circle bearing
it's
like if the Gap is
small or almost done but with this
writing condition I cannot confirm
probably what you see is what I'm seeing
okay copy that koichi and we'll have a
quick Handover coming up here in a
couple seconds if you can do a wiggle
test just to see if the boss and boss
bearing move together
and then Duke for you you can install
the lower strut mli around the clevis
understanding you've got that pit pin
installed already
[Music]
working on MLA perfect and you can also
release the the boss and uh you seems to
be working together
but now it looks like it's good but uh
in this lighting Condition it's really
difficult to see how much Gap
we have between the uh the chat box and
the spherical bearing
okay copy koichi we'll talk about that
for just a couple seconds here
and we've got a quick Handover coming in
20 seconds here but we'll have you just
install the mli on the lower strut pad
Gucci
copy that it works hey confirm I can
release my rap hey firm Duke
now in another Handover period uh we
temporarily lost video from the
International Space Station once again
um we expect a very short Handover and
we'll be getting some of that video soon
but a quick look here in Mission Control
Houston it's these teams that you're
looking at that are uh guiding the um
two astronauts through their procedures
today
um from here in the room they're working
hard to get through the procedures and
understand
um the next steps and guide both Nicole
Mann and koichiwakata through today's uh
spacewalk
probably Gucci I see that in your heck
of you
um big picture will be probably trying
to come back to this in better lighting
conditions so we can get good eyes on
uh meanwhile we'll work on that left mid
strap
copy that
okay
[Applause]
Medina can I just leave the appropriate
in the PCG green TVG here and
hey from koichi
do bigger picture next couple of steps
for you you'll be extending that mid
strut toward koichi
and then you'll be driving m28 to torque
after fuichi gets his side installed if
you want I can give you PGT settings or
we can hold off
okay I think it Remains the Same with
the um
go back or you're going to leave it
there
okay
okay
[Music]
topic Gucci you can translate to the
left side pad installation location and
once you're there check that your safer
handles are down
[Music]
okay
it looks like they came back to the
WebEx just so you know that's okay okay
then I'm gonna Translate
[Applause]
there we are
foreign
okay
nice work guys and Gucci if you could
just check that your safer handles are
down as well and then Duke you can
extend the strut to quiche
do you have an eye on my favorite animal
um let's see if you move your right hand
up
can you swing your PCT forward
foreign
copy we appreciate it
all right for that mass canister side
pad just check that the arrow is
pointing up and once you've got it from
duke engage the right side first then
press in on the left
do that
okay
[Applause]
dude could you hold it there
okay thank you
okay right side first
ah
the alignment was not
okay try that again
[Applause]
vertical alignment Tina on this one
checking quickie I think there is
a sweet spot that you will need to get
it in but I don't think that there's any
marker on it let me check
okay my
spot now
can I start with the N1 through M4 yeah
you got the side pad engaged
perfect we'll have PGT settings for you
that's Alpha two clockwise two
Alpha Duke look like too
I'm a red PGT
a firm and you'll be going two turns on
each of those bolts
and hey koichi looks like that side pad
has uh got a mind of its own and popped
off there okay
resident okay
do it again
okay dude I'm gonna
right side first okay
big o'clockwise
[Music]
copy
take two times on M1
Returns on him once copy quiche and
standby we're seeing a little bit of
movement in that side pad if you could
just kind of push on it or give it a
little bit of a a pull test
it was not engaged
is there a tough talk feature to this
one hey firm there is a soft dock
feature so if you start from the right
side there's kind of a lip that you have
to engage underneath the plate that
you're driving the bolts into
so see if you can get that hooked yeah
and then press down on the left side
my little bit closer to the right side
area
a little further
yeah so that's the uh
that's enough room but it seems like
it's in the tough talk but it didn't
they're both
at least one more do not engaged I'm
just looking at it
yeah it looks like it's in a good spot
but it doesn't go in
yeah koichi there's still a little bit
of a gap we have a not a great
view in your hecka
I agree
so what I'm trying to
providing it somehow it does not go in
fully
doesn't go in
okay copy that kuichi uh one thing that
might help is having Duke add some
leverage on her end and just to correct
one thing that I said earlier there's
not actually a sweet spot vertically in
that alignment the soft dock should work
uh anywhere vertically on that physical
structure
okay I understand so so this time
I will have uh you can pushed in right
yeah have her push it in and towards you
know
let me go through a different angle
there you go
let me know
okay looks like it's fits in a good spot
could you push
um
I'm looking at I don't know if you've
seen this view but it just doesn't go in
looks like it's uh vertically
Divine to me it's a symmetrical
on the episode and Lower Side
but
the left side of the pad does not go in
okay copy all of it
we've got some troubleshooting steps for
you here if you take it off
you'll want to look on the underside of
that side pad and we're going to have
you check that the ball detents there
are two of them on the side pad check
that they can be depressed you can use
the hook on one of your uh adjustables
or a red
let me check
yeah they can move
the defense can move
copy that Gucci standby
foreign
what I mean
okay koichi so on the right side you'll
see there's kind of a tongue
on the soft capture mechanism
on the side path yeah so that tongue
will have to fit into a gap on the right
side
there shouldn't be much of a sweet spot
but just try uh installing it partially
and moving it up and down to see if it
will slot into place
okay
amen again
[Applause]
we'll have you guys try working on this
for five or six more minutes and then
we'll formulate another plan thank you
okay
is there a spot for that little lip to
go into on the right side can we see
this is
about five it looks like it's engaged
about that
[Applause]
because he didn't doesn't go in
copy koichi I'm wondering if that mli on
the left side is in the way left or the
right side
okay so uh you want me to
remove the MRI
and try that
yeah koichi if you're able to peel up
that mli a little bit on the right side
there's a gap
exactly yep
and we'll just get that out of the way
fully
and also the left side
yeah I concur with that based on what
I've seen in your in your view stand by
and we'll figure something out okay
you can peel up the left side of the mli
as well and try to get that out of the
way
okay copy that
looks like it's include on too
now it is it is welcome
okay nice work Gucci
okay then let me put this let me try to
engage this
dick just checking in how you doing over
there
okay let's say that again
you know unfortunately he knows ours
that looks like a good move that you
just did
we'll give it one more try if you can go
up and down with that side pad
and then push in on the left side if
Duke can apply some Force as well
give you a little extra
towards me I know that telescoping
feature is probably not helping you here
okay you can release the force okay
okay because you're gonna get now okay
push it
where your right hand was just then
see if you can flip that back make sure
that that's not in the way
okay
I'll put it back
uh this uh
quickly from this angle it looks like I
don't see the lip for the right side to
engage on the back Jennifer
okay
let me let me put the back of it then
okay all right thank you
okay let me check that but
it's enough space
yeah do you have a heck of you
not quite
sure you're a little bit better to your
right
that side pad
how about now
can you see that negative Gucci we're
probably gonna have you pull off of this
task and we'll just put this strut back
in the bag
okay
negative Duke
what we're going to have you do is
compress the mid strut and put it back
on your brt and we're going to work a
forward plan from here we'll need to do
some rearranging koichi meanwhile if you
could take some pictures of that
location uh just get the left side and
the right side and all angles that
you're able to reach
copy that
what were you trying to say did you say
that this is
to me
but uh
Francis
on this side I don't know if
you know if you have you have a camera
but yeah
is disappearing with the uh the fight
tab
just left but it's different than that
the other side
um
yeah we copy everything quick hand over
here
so we're in another Handover period
um now getting live views from the
inside of the International Space
Station flight control room a quick
recap
um there's a little bit of
troubleshooting on that left middle
strut it didn't seem too soft dock
properly to that side pad on the Mast
canister for them to get a really good
secure uh latch to it and allow them to
drive the bolts so what the teams are
deciding to do now is they're going to
Stow that middle left strut and and
address the installation at a later date
in the meantime
koichiwakata is taking photos to allow
the ground teams to assess and
troubleshoot and come up with
recommendations so they can address it
the next time they're out there to
install it but it looks like uh they'll
be just leaving it in the configuration
with the upper triangle the right middle
and right lower strut and then the left
lower strut and then they'll just leave
um they'll leave the middle uh the left
middle strut off for uh this today's
installation
big picture here we're gonna wrap up uh
we need to get into some cleanup steps
and get you guys back inside so what we
want you to do is Duke you'll compress
that mid strut put it on your brt
get it back in the strut bag that's
straps two and three
koichi you can close out those pictures
and then we'll be having you help with
cleanup as well
okay copy that
thank you okay
uh
foreign
copy that Duke
and
once you have that on your brt you'll
take that picture
one other thing we want to think about
is the right upper strut that still
needs the mli covering M13 and M14 so
we'll work a forward plan for that but
if you guys have suggestions based on
what you're seeing let us know
okay do you want 15 and 16 covers right
now even though we don't have them
that's right in
checking
yeah a firm Duke if you can do that that
would be great go ahead
here
Gucci we'll have you do the right upper
mli to cover M13 and M14
and yeah
my back that you took off there okay
yeah yeah after that but I was all right
later you're gonna want that MRI over
the color though
yes Duke we will want the mli over those
collar bolts as well
okay so uh fair enough could you say
again I need to work on now
[Music]
foreign
Before you depart if you can took that
Moi a little bit better
just make sure that everything's covered
there
buddy what like that though as you can
see this uh color velcro was already
exposed so I think this is the initial
condition
we copy which you concur with that you
can head to the right upper strut work
on the mli on M13 M14
so uh to go to the right upper strut
s they can pass can I take
koichi will have you just backtrack the
way that you got there in the first
place just go back around
about right excuse me not the left the
right side okay copy that yeah correct
yeah the right side yep yeah yeah sorry
I thought it was a left side okay copy
that
so Xena do you want me to roll this APF
all over so I can get this MRI on the
right side I can grab it
or you're gonna have him translate on
the right extra checking Duke
[Applause]
foreign
that mid strut back in the strut bag
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
okay so you know they MRIs that you want
me to work on is the
complete great work
copy that
and Duke for you for that uh mid-stret
back in the strut bag that'll be strap
two and three ideally
oh
can I just uh cover the uh those M13 and
14 volts let's give you the M24 volts on
this uh
yeah we need the whole strut to be
covered with mli
so a quick recap uh wakata and man uh
both working in tandem for cleaning up
their work site man is working on
putting that left metal strut back in
the strut bag uh and stowing it to be
installed at a later date and wakata is
over on the right strut side working on
the multi-layer insulation and making
sure that the insulation is covering
some of the bolts that they were working
on today Luigi once you get that Emma
and these are both uh over closeout
duties
you'll also want to install two wire
Ties on the telescoping and
and Duke for you after you get that
mid-stret stove we'll want you to
translate to the apfr and grab the TGT
and torque wrench
foreign
ERS for you guys right now we're at five
and a half hours pet our limiting
consumable is still medox but we've got
a little over seven hours of pet time
there so we just want you guys to get
everything in a good config to leave it
we'll be coming back out for this mod
kit but we'll be
into cleanup and then getting you guys
back inside
okay
that covers the M24 the big
uh go first so that the MRI that covers
the M13 and 14 goes first
for the order doesn't matter
there's no specified order guichi
okay copy that
dude I'm thinking about putting the
strut in the middle of the bag if I put
the end where it came out
uh I think that might be a little more
like symmetrical would be better do you
agree I like that plan Duke
and then Duke while you're there
actually before we have you grabbing
that uh PGT and torque wrench from the
apfr we'll have you just bundle up that
strut bag as low profile as possible so
kind of burrito it around that strut
yeah they'll be going back in the cable
bag eventually
same with the GoPro and Defector
Duke for that strut whatever works best
for you you really only need one of
those straps add another one if it helps
hold it in place for bundling Ops but it
doesn't need to be pretty just bag it up
copy Duke that sounds great
foreign
tie right where your hand just was to
help keep that flap closed
[Music]
yeah it works
foreign
foreign
that's totally fine and I think we're
actually going to have you uh leave this
strut bag as is and have you go work
tool gathered for the cable bag but
stand by one let me clarify
okay
okay try to get a look down while you're
Secrets talking about it
Vietnam
[Music]
between the color Vault and and 24
correct
that looks great that's in a good spot
[Applause]
take three points here
yeah you'll be exactly that
[Applause]
you need inventory in the factory were
you able to see everything
no we've been watching on heca Duke
I think with that we will have you here
copy
and then let me get Delta since I got
into my hands here
okay copy
that is great
at least that looks great Duke with that
we can have you translate to the apfr
you'll retrieve the PGT and torque
wrench and then bring those to the cable
bag and sew them in the cable bag
happy
birthday
is this a good spot for the second Wi-Fi
that looks great koichi with that you
can finish up there we'll have you
translate to the strut bag
you're going to be finishing folding the
strut bag uh make it low profile enough
for you to take it back inside you'll be
stowing it on your brt and then
translating to the Anchor hooks okay
cool
[Music]
that is above me right now
heavy uh finish this up and then I'll
translate down so that I can be clear I
need to um
watch it and then I'm gonna be outboard
or imported you so okay I will stay here
then I'll tell you clear okay yeah don't
need to be yes we like that plan do you
see my face each other looks like
it was kind of routing
yeah
together
[Music]
and then
uh it should be good yeah okay yeah
okay I'll just stay here I'm very clear
of the safety center of my things
so I'm going to release it okay
stop you duke
and as you pitched forward just then
koichi's safety tether went between your
legs so just be aware of that
it's clear now but it's in a in the zone
great
I am
but then with that I would translate
I'm still here yeah so I'll figure I
need to go inboard though just so you
know all right
and I will start something
okay I've got it I'm moving copy and
Duke if you can reach it just fold that
Ingress Aid down so that we can leave
the apfr in place
we're gonna leave it okay
and I did roll it back to Foxtrot just
for your uh
anything okay copy we'll track that
and Duke we can either have you fold
that interstate down or koichi we'll
leave it up to you
okay I think I'm right here
down
copy Duke
and koichi just Trend yourself toward
the mass canister so you're not
translating on that mod kit
copy that
better
you are okay
so a quick review
um the two astronauts Nicole Mann and
koichiwakata uh out at the outside of
the International Space Station have
installed several of the struts needed
to construct the modification kit on the
1A Channel they were not able to
successfully install the left middle
strut
um the side pad on the mass canister did
not engage properly so right now they're
working on cleanup steps they're stowing
a lot of their tools and including the
left middle strut and making sure that
the multi-layer insulation that white
fabric that surrounds the mounting
platform isn't a good configuration it
is going to maintain the Integrity of
the hardware uh Emma Once everything
looks good the two will translate or
move back into the airlock tend it
toward the lower strut there
specifically the left side
okay yeah so the the other side from
where you are now
you got the right lower shot you're
talking about
for the left lower stretch yeah sorry
kuichi that's going to be the left lower
so actually not the area where you are
now you'll be translating to the other
side okay
foreign
check in kuichi
okay
yeah koichi unfortunately you'll need to
go down and around to the other side and
then back up
okay I'll be back
if you want you can try to see if you
can reach we just can't have you
translating on the mod kit since we
don't have the collar bolts torqued
right right understand that but like I'm
sorry translate around the BGA right
that's great
okay yeah I came from break this way
yep
because if I just could not surveyed on
the uh the market so I had to go around
okay
if you're far yeah
have to take that back
the original plan copy
because you know I'm bundling this okay
the cable bag isn't going on my brt
standby Duke
Duke first we'll have you grab the mutt
end effector with the GoPro Stow that in
the cable bag and then yes you'll be
putting the cable back on your brt and
getting ready to head in
copy
foreign
[Music]
yeah that's correct
it's already uh why I tried
to put the one wire car on the lower set
you know the three twists same as the
right side
yeah
koichi big picture that uh trunium pin
that your right hand is on right now we
were worried that the Cable Bundle might
snag on that when we go to rotate the
BGA uh snag on that or on the apfr okay
so we just want to attend it as close as
possible to that lower strut just to
make sure that it'll clear
securing one side so I will apply
[Music]
um
one more uh one more time around the
handrail on the uh
the one outside left side bundle that
sounds great Luigi good plan just get
that big flip of the bundle okay close
tied into that left lower strut as
possible
already exists
yeah you can use the existing one
copy that
foreign
copy that yeah if you can read it in the
bag and then close up the cable bag
[Music]
s
[Applause]
I see that in your heck of you we'll
make sure that everybody agrees but that
looks really good to me and I'll have
some big picture words for you in just a
second about our final steps to get you
guys ingressed
okay
foreign
we'll have you actually add one more
wire tie looks like the loop of that
Cable Bundle is still hanging down a bit
towards that trunnion pin and we're not
convinced that it will clear if you see
that Loop that's closest to your right
hand on the trunnion pin right now we
just want to get that up and out of the
way
is probably the easiest
okay copy that I will do that
yeah kuichi I think if you can get a
wire tie around that just like you have
your hand doing right now and then take
it up to the tether point on the
mounting bracket itself
is here
you're talking about this apron
okay and all right
I have a short while you die and I might
not
give me enough
to do that
killed by a Thai has not given us
plans to get there through the years
yeah
copy that kuichi if you're able to just
kind of feed it through the tether point
uh and then the
the wire tie doesn't necessarily have to
loop back onto itself so you could have
one twist up top on the tether point and
then the other end going down to the
Cable Bundle I'm not sure that's enough
length
let me work an alternate plan for you
just a sec
yeah probably not
I'm gonna put this on my PRT and had
inboard if you agree
Duke let's have you work on the strut
bag see if you can get that any more
folded and ready to go for koichi to
eventually put that on his brt and then
we'll have you head back in copy
okay
can I try to uh use my short wire tie
from this
better point on the mounting brackets
hey firm koichi I think if you take off
the wire tie that you just added a
couple steps ago
and then move the whole thing up
or sorry the uh the one that was already
the existing wire tie
undo it from where you just added twists
and then move the whole bundle further
up that lower strut as close to the
mounting bracket as possible
okay let me try that see if you can get
that wire tied to kind of hug the whole
Cable Bundle to the strut
okay
my cooling is at six
copy six Duke
foreign
big picture guys we're just shy of six
hours on pet here you're limiting
consumable still has a little over seven
hours for medox so you're doing a good
job keep it up with the cleanup and
we'll get you back inside
copy that
you know this is what you're talking
about so I'm gonna attractive noise
excuse me
hey firm that's a good plan kuichi
a quick review of the work done so far
right now the astronauts are doing some
cleanup duties during an orbital night
time the space station is flying 264
statue miles
um over Western Europe right now
uh they're just making sure their work
site is in a good configuration so it
can be addressed during a future
spacewalk so they're using wire ties to
make sure the cables are secure they're
checking the multi-layer insulation
putting their tools away in their
respective bags uh just making sure the
work site over at the 1A power channel
is is in a good configuration to leave
it so they can schedule a spacewalk at a
later time to finish some of the work
over here they started on the
construction of the 1A modification kit
and was not able they were not able to
install that left middle strut they took
some photos of the ground teams can
assess some of that work and uh figure
out what
um steps need to be put into place to
make sure that they can have a secure
attachment of that left strut to the
mass canister and the whole fixture that
will soon be holding up future irosa or
International Space Station
um
pull out solar arrays those set to be
delivered to the International Space
Station this summer again there are four
total that are already there on the
space station installed and providing
power
um there they were today during today's
Space Walk we're working on modification
kits for two power channels
Gucci if you could tilt up so that we
can see the mounting bracket just want
to get one last heck of survey here
okay
koichi that looks great we are really
happy with that config with that you can
leave that work site you'll head back
toward Duke and help finish up the strut
bag
eventually you'll be putting the strut
bag on your brt
she'll lead the translation back in and
you'll follow back to the Anchor Hooks
and then continue to Ingress
do that
foreign
[Applause]
for your kids are being wrong
I think I think it's up to your judgment
koichi is going to be translating back
in with this on his brt so we'll leave
it to your encuichi's judgment about
what's going to work
okay
other end
I think that'll just help out some small
houses perspective yeah I like that plan
you will be taking it back into the crew
lock with you
okay so can we see um okay
yeah I'm just going to release so it's
still going to be passed down at the
outward and back down okay
so just run
locations okay all right I'll translate
towards you now
foreign
tether we just want to make sure that
it's not going back around the Mast
canister and that you'll be good to head
inboard from where you are
I I did not go uh yeah save each other
is with me and I'm going
outboard to this
grapple fixture area so it's clear from
the BGA
happy Gucci
foreign
we'll have you start heading inboard
if it helps to both be there together
well Luigi puts it on his brt let us
know but we'd like to prioritize just
getting used back in board we'll get
that strut bag on kuichi's brt and he'll
follow you in
okay yeah it doesn't look pretty but
it's uh I think it's gonna be small
enough that it won't give him a problem
um
location okay is that on the outboard
side
to the nearest you it's got one
integrated uh cover okay
I'm gonna head um import to the and grab
the cable box
sounds great
when I got your um let me just uh before
you go more I have your your planner
packs here so let me just get out of
your way okay I stay here so
we copy all we'll also take a glove and
hap check from both of you
okay uh easy one
plus the first happy space song
and my contents are down
but I'll get it in a second Tina
Gucci and coffee Duke we're about a
minute from a quick Handover
[Applause]
my hop is uh Baseline
oh my god look good oh my God my foot
down
foreign
over period losing that video from the
International Space Station will be
regaining it shortly right now wakata
and man are both
um still at the work site where they've
been for the past couple of hours now
six hours and six minutes into today's
space walk they've wrapped up their
cleanup duties really just taking those
last tools and making sure they're
stowed or in the case of the strut bag
attached to their body restraint tether
so they can tow it back with them but
the main objective now is to get back to
the airlock they're going to get back
into the crew uh the crew lock of the
airlock this is where
um they'll close the hatch and
re-pressurize to 14.7 psi the pressure
of the International Space Station and
get back inside
copy quiche that's great news you can
start following Duke back in
okay
[Music]
okay
I see you I know
wait for you
oh shut back it's really long
time
we copy that
and Gucci reminder you'll be going
inboard towards those anchor hooks
they're Nader of the Cedar Park
okay
let me just
didn't take it down and then I'll move
okay
Did You Have Eyes on your safety feather
are you clear is it clear of me
Tangled on anything
it's in front of you okay
running through your the media work
taking area
okay I'll just watch it as I go
okay I'm headed out okay okay
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I'll just follow you
foreign
okay copy that I am behind you
foreign
[Music]
will be able to clear it for you so that
you don't have to go back outboard Duke
and just a reminder for koichi you'll be
performing at those anchor hooks okay
safe in the airlock
okay copy that
let me clear that
all right
they should be cleared out
um
[Applause]
okay
okay so let me clear that okay
all right so
let me come a little bit uh outboard
because my telepath is right here and so
it's not okay uh
[Applause]
yeah this feather is going through your
mini Mark station so let me
clear that
okay let me
know
down real quick yeah okay
I have also locals that uh at your
locals
okay great then uh let me try to clear
that
okay
okay
area with uh
shall I rotate like this just a moment
don't move
I think it's just on the wrong side of
this header pack because the anchors is
right by each other right
s here and then here it's running here
and then now okay let me clear on this
side
through here
okay
foreign
very nice
how long till there's clear
my left side I should have my I have my
weight Center and then I think each
other it will be good
yeah that's uh
okay now
put together around your
brt and the cable bag
oh it should be clear
another uh brief lapse in video from the
International Space Station again all of
these are just a matter of seconds
really so we'll be regaining that
shortly and should hear voice from the
International Space Station here soon
boy we're witnessing was uh both
koichiwakata and Nicole Mann translating
or moving back to the airlock along the
way they were making sure that they were
in a good configuration with their
tethers that actually keep them anchored
to the International Space Station as a
safety precaution so they are just
making sure that the tethers are where
they're supposed to be and where they
expect them to be and they're not
Tangled
um so they're working together to just
make sure those are in a good
configuration as they continue to work
their way back to the airlock without
six hours 18 minutes into today's space
walk that hook
okay perfect amazing we are clear right
carry on then
all right
okay now as I say that I still see it
your safety center here
you have a class yet
okay so now if you have guys on the
anchors
okay
Crystal uh
I don't know if that's that's your
anchor do you see it okay
foreign
[Applause]
okay all right should be clear now but
it's wrapped around this
we'll leave the Judgment up to you guys
but if it helps you can put down a waste
tether lock the hook block on black and
undo the anchor hook in order to clear
any snacks that you're seeing
okay
my anchor
I'm releasing my anchor hook
okay
do you want my ankle hook while we're
here you might as well take it
okay
for me local then
local okay
so but the uh
this one I can take it yeah
just a moment
[Applause]
okay left weight feathers and that's to
do hook
take clothes on both sides
local
[Applause]
okay
copy we're tracking both hooks are
locked black on black that's a good load
pass
okay I'm releasing my uh unlocking my
local and uh
all right
thank you
and then I just wanted to report the uh
my CCA on the left side is not working
so I can hear from my right side only
copy and we'll have you guys stand by
we want to make sure that we really
understand this tether config that we're
in before you send we send you anywhere
okay
come closer to the beach
okay guys with both kuichi's waist
tether locked
and Duke's anchor hook locks two
koichi's waist tether and kuichi's
anchor hook
still attached to structure lock on
block we're good with this config you
can head inboard Duke and we'll get you
on the airlock hearing extender
and I'm going to uh
there you go
all right
and just to be super clear Duke's gonna
go ahead and board koichi you'll stay
put until Duke is safe in the airlock
and then after she re-establishes yep
exactly you'll be cleaning up the
slingshot
see that I will wait
okay okay
yes I did
okay thank you that'll be great
all right
I'll be following you
15 I I already uh put the uh
different breaks on the outboard side
twice
we'll just have you stay put okay I'm on
the uh
copy Duke
and koichi we appreciate the get ahead
but we will have you also uh touch those
breaks one more time as you head inboard
just to make sure that that's the last
thing on the cedar cart that you touch
understand
foreign
and quiche just making sure we'll have
you stay put right where you are and
wait until the Duke gets back in the
airlock
it's changing the local position
copy that kuichi
everything
okay copy that
foreign
great work Duke
heads up we're at about six and a half
hours pet
puppy
I'm opening the thermal cover
thank you
I'm about to open it
so right now duke or NASA astronaut
Nicole Mann has arrived at the airlock
she's going to open up the thermal cover
and get it prepared um so she can
Ingress
but koichiwakata is standing by with the
strut bag in tow
that stock bag has that final strut the
mid left strut that they're going to be
bringing back into the airlock with them
so he's just standing by for now as uh
man gets the hatch configured block on
block
okay
copy that's great news
koichi you can go ahead and head inward
you'll pick up your anchor Hook from
handrail 3011 stow it on your mini
workstation and translate in you will
need to press the starboard seater
breaks and the port Cedar bricks on your
way in
copy that they work
again I'm going to work on getting this
bag in here
copy Duke like that plan
great
old twice complete
10 minutes that sounds lady
and heads up for both of you especially
Duke right now we were tracking in the
airlock one of the large small rats that
strung out
is locked so that it might be kind of a
loose snag Hazard as you head in
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
making his way back to the airlock
this whole time he's been in the suit
with red stripes he's got that strut bag
in tow
meanwhile Nicole man call sign Duke
wearing the suit with no stripes
firm you did hit those feeder bricks I
didn't have good eyes on
uh
shortly perfect thank you
Duke once you have that cable bag stowed
on the airlock during extender Rhett
we'll have you turn off your heka and
Ingress
okay uh port side uh
copy thanks so much squeegee
[Applause]
now A good view of the airlock
let's ask NASA astronaut Nicole Mann
making her way into the airlock after
getting a go to do so
very shortly we'll be seeing
koichiwakata
I'll be taking up the rear and exiting
or entering the crew lock last
it'll be his job to make sure the strut
bag which is currently on his body
restraint tether of the spacesuit gets
uh maneuvered into the crew lock with
them he'll be the one to close that
thermal cover the
um soft fabric flap that goes over the
hatch to the crew lock
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
just make sure for us that you have
access to it and that you'll be able to
install it when the time comes
area
happy Gucci we see ya
[Applause]
yeah my umbilical's behind the hatch
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
get you some steps for people shooting
up here
and at your convenience for both of you
we'll take one final tcv setting just
before we get you hooked up on them Bill
house
but I have not changed it since my last
color okay I have not changed it
[Applause]
for anyone
[Applause]
yes correct
okay copy we're tracking six for both of
you
foreign
right
ground copies everything pointy let's
just have you hang out there to give
Duke maximum space for trying to get
that SCU out from behind the hatch
copy that
okay
behind the hatch a little bit
but I cannot I have enough Flack it
reaches me
I think it'll be a problem
[Applause]
is that okay you know copy Duke and uh
you don't see any way that it would be
in the way of the hatch actually
operating
behind the house
um
yeah it's like in the top
uh like the penis corner of the house
but I think for that'll solve the
problem
okay copy
I think if I pull it all the way out
it'll be more of a snack hazard
because all the velcros come off
standby Duke we're checking
foreign
if you are confident that you have
enough slack to actually connect the Su
to your DCM and that it's not going to
interfere with the hatch operation we're
good with that config and Gucci you can
then continue to Ingress the airlock and
turn off your heka as you Ingress
hey
okay yeah it looks great like it's going
to be no problem uh closing that hatch
and I definitely have Flex okay that's
perfect great news with that koichi will
have you Ingress and turn off your
haircut
okay
thermal cover so if you want to attach
and each other's do it Now's the Time
okay
can I start working on my SVU now or do
I need to wait
you can we'll also have you receive that
strut bag in the best way possible from
koichi and I think he should do that
before he tries to Ingress
okay
coming in
okay still read it for me okay let me
get that down okay
ah
um
okay
can you release the red from there
okay great thank you got it
okay peanut with that uh to have us all
doing great
see you can Ingress turn off your hecka
as you Ingress
and then you'll be closing the hatch
thermal cover okay releasing The Hook
from its stowage point and attaching the
hook to the magnetic plate d-ring and
cinching the strap until you see six
times
the Ava team uh especially uh Chloe
married
2010 and
yeah
he's putting together the excellent work
procedures and executing it then we
encountered the you know challenges and
but I appreciate your flexibility to
safely return us to to the airlock and I
also like to thank a trainer
uh Mark Wilson
and David Simon for joining us on the
Emu systems in making a city to our Eva
and I know that the team has supporting
this year in Houston and it's Cuba and I
really like to thank to all of them
[Applause]
um
thanks again
thank you for those kind words
congratulations on your Eva let's get
you inside and safe on that SCU really
proud of this team and all of the hard
work thank you both so much
you to the DCM just make sure that it
won't be a snag Hazard for kuichi as
he's ingressing
okay
in here
can we see you looking good that step
back is above your
head okay and the cable bag is Venus you
should be clear though
okay let me get the uh
thermal cover
in case you missed it uh koichiwakada
gave some congratulatory and thankful
words to the teams that made it possible
for he and NASA astronaut Nicole Mann to
conduct today's spacewalk
um this is his final words before he
enters the crew lock and they begin the
repressurization sequence Nicole man is
already in the crew lock just waiting
for the next steps to hook up her
umbilical
um to the International Space Station
her suit's still on the portable life
support system but that umbilical will
provide water and oxygen and other power
and other consumables to be transferred
directly from station to the astronauts
so we'll just wait for kuichiwakata to
make his Ingress successful and then
we'll begin the repressurization shortly
after coming in
okay and get the hook back to the
magnetic plate d-ring and the strap
cinched and just verify that the magnet
is engaged
okay it's a little bit further
okay all right
foreign
suggestion let me
this is my mini workstation ended up
[Applause]
and then Duke just let us know when you
have your seu connected to the DCM
once you do just a note that a tcv
setting between 8 and Max cooling will
minimize the time necessary to get
cooling on your ECU
copy that
okay okay
but that's
and I'm fencing down the strap
[Applause]
one two three
two three four five six seven nine
[Applause]
yeah
and copy Duke you are connected to that
too
foreign
[Music]
reminder for you as well tcv between 8
and Max cooling will minimize time
necessary for cooling on a cu
copy that
foreign
foreign
foreign
all happy to have you both back on SVU
with that you can switch water to off
that's the forward position expect H2O
is off message on your DCU
okay copy that you are in work
photos
coffee water is off for both of you
we've started a two minute timer
once that timer is up you'll be getting
ready to close the hatch
so a quick recap both astronauts are
inside the crew lock right now they're
hooked up by umbilical to the
International Space Station
they're setting a timer for uh the
procedures to
get ready uh get the suits ready and
themselves ready before closing the
hatch and be getting the
repressurization process uh the clock is
still going for today's space walk and
it'll officially stop once we start that
repressurization
[Applause]
let me know yeah this is great perfect
thank you
foreign
foreign
guys we've got the two minute timer up
verify the outer hatch is clear of
hardware
and verify the handle position is per
the hatch decal
then you'll close unlock the hatch
okay
didn't work
foreign
I go a little more stubborn
continue
I'm hitting something that I cannot go
any further
you you see my fetus okay
um
and you can come out
okay but um okay
we're another uh brief Handover period
again this one is also relatively short
so we'll be getting that video
um back from the International Space
Station very shortly already have some
audio the crew are inside the crew lock
right now they're going through their
steps
um to get the hatch closed inside the
crew lock there's a couple more steps
for the umbilicals just to provide
oxygen and power through the
International Space Station to them
before they begin that repressurization
forward can you
Decay 17.5 volts DC
I need to go out
go
upstairs
you can acknowledge the message Duke
is clear now can we see
okay I think it's good now
okay that's good okay so you called
yourself
okay
positions
that's close
[Applause]
in
collecting directions
coffee that is great news we are with
that moving into our repress cue card
okay on your DCM just check for me that
your scus are connected to your DCM and
check that the water switch is off
okay okay
connected and water is off for you
because
copy both check that the Ed hatch is
closed and locked
on the UIA
check that the oxygen for emu one and
two valve is open
for easy one and three one and two are
open
switch power for ev1 and 2 to on
green LEDs
copy good green LEDs check that the
power voltage is between 18 and 19 for
both
for 18.6
copy on your DCM switch power to SCU
expect a warning tone
[Music]
did we stagger this one Xena
negative you don't need to stagger this
one
[Applause]
foreign
Space Station
just like in the beginning of the day
Frank Rubio and Josh Casada NASA
astronauts inside the equipment lock on
the other side of that hatch is our two
spacewalking astronauts that hatch is
down to vacuum right now and then once
both of you you have switched power to
SCU I'll be ready to hand it over to
Frank we can see him there in the
equipment lock
s it worked
um
copy ev2
foreign
thank you
great work both of you copy you are both
now on SGU power with that I can hand it
over to Frank thank you both for your
incredibly hard work lots of strength
and Grace doing with so much for Nikki
Hardware today thank you for this
incredible Eva grateful for the
opportunity to work with you both over
to Frank
thank you
all right and yeah great job as a ground
IV thanks so much for joining us to this
point Korea Nicole it's great to have
you guys back
all right so for both of you on your
dcms take your O2 actuator to press
TV let me work
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
thank you
for koichi can we have you get a good
wiggle test on that O2 actuator just
make sure it's all the way in press
copy that
okay wiggle and these themselves
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
for those uh tuning in now uh Frank
Rubio on the inside
of the station's equipment lock is
walking the crew through the
repressurization procedure right now
they just have to make sure some of the
knobs and dials that they're turning are
all the way the ground team is assessing
to make sure that uh the crew is
following the steps very intricately
until they begin the repressurization so
they're just verifying that everything
is okay
foreign
foreign
[Music]
damn
it one more try okay all right
I don't really see uh yeah
the lateral movement is sticking
okay yeah copy we know that's a hard one
to actuate as long as you've got that
lever pushed up and the button pushed in
to move it into press
um we can let you keep working on it we
can also work an alternate plan for you
yeah that is true basically we'd just be
having you do the repress a little more
slowly to make sure that we don't
actuate sop
can we release the New York station and
uh I press the button
you get to the tabs
almost there
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
sounds like you guys are doing great
work in there if you want to we can
continue with the repress with your O2
actuator still in Eva
big picture we'd just be going a lot
more slowly Duke you would maintain
really good calms with Frank and you
would just need to keep your suit
pressure monitoring your suit pressure
to make sure that Delta p is above four
for the duration of the repress and that
will keep us from activating your sop
[Applause]
remove it
right thirty thousand and then that's
right let's take a look
let me know when you get the switch
what's the difference should be now
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
reminder that the process to get the two
crew members back inside the
International Space Station and
repressurize that crew lock to get them
both in is a very methodical process
[Applause]
foreign
teams are working in tandem with the
crew that you see here from your view
inside the International Space Station
all talking and monitoring along the way
making sure that they're following the
steps to get them back in
whatever is
success
okay
okay
[Applause]
they moved
slowly pictures
okay all right okay great job thank you
[Music]
okay and just to verify uh koichi I
copied you are impressed and Nicole I
understand you are also impressed now
with that confirmation they got the
actuator the oxygen oxidator where they
need to go so they're working through
the next steps
we're going to start the repress and let
me know what's a good rate I'll start
off nice and slow so IV hatch
Equalization valve I will follow from
off the norm
reminder for disregard
and you can both expect an alert Zone
and time is 20 35.
[Applause]
of that ring for both of you good for me
it's uh you can go faster for me
technically do you okay with that yeah
you can go faster
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
copies
all right so what you're hearing now is
the repressurization underway and with
the repressurization starts that is the
official end time for today's space walk
that total space walking time is 7 hours
and 21 minutes with the repressurization
beginning at 2 35 PM Central Time
foreign
[Applause]
happy
the repressurization process is in
Reverse from what we saw at the start of
today's space walk going down from 14.7
PSI down to five holding for a little
bit to make sure there were no leaks
before proceeding down to vacuum it's
now in Reverse from vacuum up to 5 PSI
same same process holding for just a
couple of minutes to make sure there are
no leaks before they continue to proceed
up to pressure matching and equalizing
that of the inside of the space station
where Frank Rubio is with his crewmates
and uh that will be up to
14.7 psi
so right now we're in a couple of minute
hold period
all right guys are two minutes of
stabilization is up now we'll do a one
minute pressure check great
okay guys uh pressure is stable so next
you will both take your glove heaters
off okay easy one
second
uh check that your glove heaters are off
okay and I heard ev2 and ev1 glove
heaters are off uh for both of you check
that your check gloves for contamination
no contamination
okay coffee for both
uh for both of you take your O2 actuator
to IV
paint marks
[Applause]
IV
[ __ ] video
okay copy 481 and E2
we are now going to go back to finish
the repress so I'll
start and then increase the rate let me
know if um you don't feel comfortable
you can expect an alert Zone both when I
start and also when DTD key is about
zero
and station Houston to question one uh
for koichi uh could you verify your O2
actuator is in Ivy
I'm gonna
okay copy that coaching good config
okay
[Applause]
and with that confirmation the
repressurization inside the crew lock
has resumed so we are increasing from 5
PSI up to equalize with the inside of
the space station which is sitting at
about 14.7 the same as we have here on
Earth as we make our way up to match
that for the International Space Station
we do have some statistics now that the
space station the spacewalk for today
has concluded uh that spacewalk again
was seven hours 21 minutes it was the
258th spacewalk in support of space
station assembly maintenance and
upgrades uh for the two space walking
astronauts it was a first it was the
first space station spacewalk in 2023
but the fifth overall during this
Expedition Expedition 68
for wakata this was his first spacewalk
so he gets the total run time for
today's spacewalk which is again seven
hours 21 minutes is the same for man
seven hours 21 minutes for her career as
well
um and that is the total run time for
today's space walk which ended at 2 35
PM central time if you take all of the
258 spacewalks that have been conducted
in support of space station assembly
maintenance and upgrades you get a total
of 68 days 5 hours and 47 minutes
now back to the action again uh Rubio on
the right and uh NASA astronaut Josh
cassida on the left uh we'll be working
to oversee the repressurization and
Ingress of the uh astronauts from the
crew lock into the equipment lock where
the two are situated once they get
inside uh the two space walking
astronauts will flank
um cassida and Rubio to the left and to
the right they'll get situated in those
racks the silver racks you see uh right
now one very clearly behind
um Josh cassida but first we got to make
our way up to equalize with the pressure
of the International Space Station and
the rate is a little faster than we saw
for the depressurization sequence so
right now we're a little more than 12
PSI again we're going to about 14.7
foreign
foreign
pressurization is complete
so Frank rubell you see turning that uh
handle to open up the hatch
ing station on one for step four
go ahead on one
second will you guys take care I'm sorry
hockey will you guys uh take care of uh
step four and one decimal two four zero
and Frank we are taking care of it
foreign
first in the hatch is uh
it has an astronaut Nicole Mann who took
on the ev2 position for today she was
the first in the hatch at the conclusion
of today's space walk
cancer and Rubio as the suit IVs they're
the ones responsible for getting both of
the astronauts situated so they can
start Doffing or taking off their suits
one of the first steps for them is at
the base of the suits backpack is a unit
called the safer that's sort of their
emergency jet pack that they would use
in the very unlikely scenario that they
were that they would become untethered
elocution on one uh EV Q is no longer
hot mic
thank you
so you can see the safer uh unit has
been removed
from the base of the backpack of
Nicole Mann's spacesuit
Josh cassida now working to collapse the
handles that went up the sides of that
backpack that's the stowage
configuration for those safer units
you'll put that in a separate location
as
Frank Rubio gets Nicole Mann situated on
the side there so they can start working
with her suit removing the helmets and
gloves and getting her comfortable and
readjusted back into the station's
internal environment meanwhile koichi
wakada you can see is still in the crew
lock he is patiently waiting his turn
um until he'll go on the right side from
this view across from where Nicole man
is situated now you can also see that
long bag that they towed all the way out
to and from the work site
inside that bag is that mid-strut
that will be uh taken out on a future
space walk to finish the installation of
uh the modification kit uh that's on the
1A power Channel
even uh with the conclusion of the
spacewalk today we'll continue our
coverage until uh they start Doffing the
suits and removing the helmets
same process for uh koichiwakata
to get him situated so Frank Rubio and
Josh cassida can continue removing the
components of the suit and get them out
so they can
um
get ready for a good night's rest really
after a long day of space walking the
space walking time of 7 hours and 21
minutes is just really the official time
of the spacewalk itself and used for
engineers for a variety of purposes
mainly in understanding the consumable
constraints and really understanding the
timeline as well
but uh for the crew it's a much much
longer day they've been in the suit for
quite some time doing pre-breathing and
into light exercises to get ready for
the spacewalk inside those spacesuits is
a 100 oxygen environment so part of the
pre-breathing exercise and and really
getting ready to go out of the hatch is
purging their body of nitrogen which
which takes uh time so they've been in
the suit for quite some time
once again uh losing video from the
International Space Station we're lucky
that most of these drops have been very
very short in duration so we are
anticipating that we'll again regain
that video from the station once again
and when we do
um as a reminder we'll continue our
coverage until they start Doffing the
suits um showing the crew and them
excited after uh after their Journey
outside to install the um
modification kit on the 1A power Channel
and then we'll wrap up our covered
shortly after that but we'll continue
for just a little bit as a reminder the
spacewalk ended after seven hours 21
minutes at uh 2 35 PM Central Time
the team here in Mission Control Houston
and the International Space Station
flight control room you see uh likely
more flight controllers than you've seen
before right now they are actually
undergoing a Handover period so as the
crew members are getting inside there
will be a new shift of flight
controllers that will get them ready for
bed and do some of the cleanup
activities that are necessary before
they enter into their pre-sleep and
sleep periods for the night
lots of activity in the equipment lock
right now just as a reminder Frank Rubio
on the far right as the suit IV uh
helping koichiwakata on the left is Josh
cassida helping with Nicole Mann and her
suit and the far back we have Rose
Cosmos Cosmonaut Sergey prokopiev taking
some photos and it seems like we have
another Rose Cosmos cosmonaut in the
background there also taking some photos
we're following along with the sudafing
process for uh Nicole Mann on the left
we will keep uh koichi wakata on the
right
uh on the right helping wakata is Frank
Rubio on the left helping man is Josh
cassida
they're working to get those gloves off
it's a lot of strain during a long Space
Walk on the Fingers
um so it will be quite a relief for the
crew members to have those gloves off it
is common that after the gloves have
been removed to take uh some photos of
the gloves if you notice throughout the
duration of the spacewalk there were
these periodic checks for the gloves and
what's called the haps the helmet
absorption pad we'll see those once the
helmets are removed but the gloves
because they are used so intensively
throughout a spacewalk they're used for
all of the translation or the movement
across the outside of the space station
they're used for all of the work using
the pistol grip tool grabbing onto
various structures sometimes they have
some Nicks and scrapes and so they
document uh after the spacewalk the
condition of the glove so we'll see we
might see some of the some photos of the
gloves but it looks like for now they're
stilling them in the various locations I
think the priority here is really get
the crew nice and comfortable now that
they've conducted the spacewalk allow
their fingers to be free
so with the gloves removed the next will
be the helmets and of course after the
helmets are removed they'll do a hap
check and all of that but after the
helmets are removed is when we'll end
our coverage for today
both helmets off for each of the
respective space walking astronauts
today who have added 7 hours and 21
minutes to their total career space
walking time a first for both of them
installing the um
uh mounting platform on the 1A power
Channel and finishing up some work on
the 1B
um they will address the one struct at a
later spacewalk and teams will decide
the appropriate course of action for
finishing the work there before the iro
says the robot solar arrays arrive in
the summer time
but for now it's the end of a successful
day for the space walking astronauts and
that'll do it for us for our coverage of
today's activities Smiles all around the
cabin uh both everyone excited for the
uh uh to astronauts who have added space
walking to their career today
and with that we'll wrap up our coverage
here this is Mission Control Houston
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
said space is the place
and I brought a few friends along who
know something about artificial
intelligence
hi I'm John
there are both artists working with NASA
this is
NASA
[Music]
that's it back you just released a set
of new music videos using a lot of NASA
imagery and I grew up living space and
obviously there's images are used by
scientists what inspires you about space
and how you came up with this idea well
the title of the record came from a
video game a really primitive video game
from the 80s called asteroids when the
asteroids were going to kill you and
they would they were just about to
collide with your spaceship that you
would hit this button and it would make
you disappear
and reappear somewhere else in in the
galaxy
uh and I always wondered what that
button was called and I looked it up one
day and it was called hyperspace so I I
sort of um it got my mind thinking into
music and song ideas because I think in
some way I think of music as sort of a
hyperspace button
you know it's something that we you know
we press play on a piece of music and it
takes us somewhere out of our lives out
of our circumstances but I did like the
the feeling of the music that there was
this sort of thread of outer space kind
of
um wide Vista of space and time you know
existing in the songs
artificial intelligence is the ability
for machines or computers to make
autonomous and Intelligent Decisions
that can look like recognizing patterns
or analyzing images or learning certain
behaviors and then mimicking them
I mean right away when we heard
hyperspace we thought we have to use AI
for this Beth was already creating a
Sonic environment that went to like the
edges of our our understanding and the
way that we see and that's something
that we're most excited about working
with AI with that it it expands our our
modes of thinking and then just the
title hyperspace literally means to go
beyond three dimensions the one that we
use for this particular project it
literally Works in a 512 dimensional
space in order the the process begins
with the AI training on the images so if
we showed it just a few hundred it
wouldn't know that much but what was so
great about working with NASA's decades
deep you know Archive of knowledge is
that it could really learn so for weeks
and weeks the AI trained on as many
images as we could show it I think in
the end it looked at over 25 million
images sometimes that was multiple times
looking at the same images to try and
understand these images
yeah basically imagery of anything in
our solar system is how we get started
in the process of exploration right and
right so when we first went to Mars or
when we sent Cassini to Saturn we had
some thoughts about what we might find
based on that imagery and that's what
allows us to really focus down on the
type of science we're going to do I
worked a lot on the database creation
and I feel almost like I could draw a
picture of
the Galaxy now just from going that like
anyone can do just by working with
Vanessa websites and going through the
archives like the AI wasn't able to take
that and
um recognize uh colors that were
happening a lot recognize shapes that
were happening a lot I remember when it
first showed us what it thought Saturn
looked like I was blown away yeah and
even then seeing these images and
getting all the info it's it's it is
overwhelming isn't it I mean we're
talking about other worlds we're talking